the gamestop
apes have actually won a very
serious battle a hedge fund that bet
against
gamestop which managed 440 million
dollars
announced it is shutting down amid
double
digit losses percentage-wise this is
huge
this could be one of the this may be one
of the biggest stories but there are a
lot of really big stories
because it's not just that it's also a
new report coming out from
the national pulse showing that google
was actually providing
funding to wuhan linked virus research
through eco health alliance
and then all the censorship kind of well
i don't want to
necessarily say it absolutely makes
sense but it raises some eyebrows you
know like
google wants to censor a lot of talk
about lab leak that was going on last
year
taking down a lot of channels for
misinformation and now we find out that
through their foundation they are
providing funding for
similar and uh wuhan linked virus
research
wow well that's going to be dangerous
and maybe we'll get banned um
if we don't get banned for that we'll
probably get banned because steve
bannon's hanging out with us
how's it going man they're going very
well do you want to just briefly
introduce yourself
i'm steve bannon there you go your
producer said be brief
uh it's a tough there's a tight ship
over here no you wanna you wanna uh uh
i'm sure
i'm gonna go look i'm honored to be here
because i've wanted your audience is an
audience that uh you know we're
on the populist right you know you came
out of the occupying movement you're the
populist left
uh i think there's a lot of commonality
i think today the the story
of the apes transcends politics i think
it cuts to the heart it's one of the
most important stories in the world what
i call you know
the verticals of work of the populist
movement and it blew up a hedge fund
today
in london and more to come more to come
as they as they buy and hold
and and do not retreat uh this uh
group of basically deplorables or the
little guy or the common man whatever
you want to say
is relentless and they're marching to
the heart of the incompetence and
corruption that
is the rigged casino that is wall street
now
i'll tell you how rigged it is on the
way up here kind of you know getting
ready for maybe some topics
seeking alpha a great site right out
there great financial site with short
stories
has a headline uh amc time to sell
right and so i read this and it's got
this very fundamental analysis about the
stocks overvalued net present value all
this stuff
and it's all these reasons that this
thing is going to collapse price wise
and you get all the way down to the
bottom
and the guy says for full disclosure the
very bottom time print in full
disclosure
i'm short i said you can't make this
up seeking alpha why don't you put that
in the headline a short says
it's time for you guys this guy is
sweating bullets he's
oh sure he is his losses are infinite
it's the sweet hour of prayer for all
these smart guys this is the power of i
think the apes
you know having gone to harvard business
school and having worked at goldman
sachs in the merger department right
back then was the elite of the elite
is you see these people crowdsourcing
and this is how
modern technology has dis-intermediate
institutions
the reason your show is so big the
reason we can do the war room
you know where we do it and we get
traction it's not like the old days
there's reason trump
one of the reasons trump won the
presidency was twitter he could
disintermediate
the mainstream media right what you're
seeing with the crowd sourcing of
financial knowledge we had brittany
avery
uh one of the one of the the apes on the
other she's the
young woman that's done the a mother of
two in missoula montana
that has done these billboards of the
apes we should we should i don't want to
do too much because
she comes on and says hey i said she
says oh you know i'm just in this stock
and i said well
when did you buy it she goes january
first time i bought a stock and i go oh
what was the price two dollars the
stock's at 60.
guys on wall street dine out for a
career
on that trade right i bought it too i
got my clients out at 60. they will
literally get clients the rest of their
life on that one trade
and she's saying oh yeah i just kind of
bought it too and but her knowledge
the collective knowledge we're gonna get
into all that too i don't want to do too
much just yet we'll go through the
intros
so uh but without uh i don't i don't
think we need to introduce you beyond
you're steve bannon to be completely
honest i think most people know who you
are
ian i heard billboard of apes i'm sold
that sounds awesome to me
uh great good to see you man hey thanks
for having me yeah buddy
and then i'm also here in the corner i'm
very excited for this conversation i'm
really going to get into it especially
about populism which i think absolutely
transcends party so i'm stoked about it
amen
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member
because i'll tell you this a lot of
things youtube doesn't
a lot of people talk about i mentioned
this briefly in the intro there's a new
story showing that google was actually
providing funding for some of this wuhan
linked virus research which i think
is going to piss off a lot of people at
google so
here's what we have to do we we accept
where we win we accept where we can lose
and one of the opportunities here is we
set up timcast.com the new website is
launching uh in a couple of weeks we
have a new news section we have
cassandra fairbanks writing
we just hired another writer who's going
to be doing unexplained culture building
stuff
mysteries kind of articles and we're
we're going to have a bonus segment with
steve up around 11 p.m after the show
we're going to record another segment
where we're going to get into a lot of
these subjects that we would be
instantly banned on youtube for talking
about
i know it's tough i wish we could just
come out and say all of it but you
choose your battles
and i think there's an opportunity to
inform people those conversations will
be happening so go to timcast.com become
a member but don't forget
like this video right now subscribe to
this channel
and if you think these conversations are
important and if you think cnn is awful
and we deserve more viewers than they do
share the podcast share the video and
that's true for any video you like
because there is more power in the all
of these individuals who are watching
this show
to share and spread the message than in
any amount of marketing budget
these big marketing companies would beg
and pray for the power you could get
from a viral movement or grassroots
movement they try they're not good at it
they put up billboards let's see if we
can beat them let's jump into this first
story we'll kick back off where we just
were with these with these hedge funds
check this story out this is amazing i
almost i want to get a standing ovation
to the game stop the amc
the the the meme stock apes is
incredible
you've taken a hedge fund look at the
cnet reports hedge fund that bet against
gamestop is closing down
it's game over for white scare white
square capital
it managed 440 million thousand assets
at its peak it sent a letter to
investors selling plans to close down
the main fund
this month and return investor capital
following a review of the business model
according to the report
they they're they're announcing a double
digit percentage
loss suffered by the first meme stock
rally
in january and oh boy it's only just
begun
so now what you have is and correct me
if i'm wrong steve you have a lot of
these big hedge funds
that they manipulate the game they they
they
it's it's a manipulated casino it's a
rigged game they can short a company
then their friends in the media say oh
this company's bad and it's going to
crash you better sell now
causing the stock price to plummet and
then the short sellers make off like
bandits
stripping and manipulating all of us so
what happens is
these uh these memestock apes are like
so these people have no choice but to
buy
stocks you know what to cover their
shorts yes
so that means if we all buy them right
now and the price goes up they're forced
to buy them from us yes
let's play now hedge funds just imploded
can they alternately declare bankruptcy
and just wash the debt the hedge funds
they're leveraged here's the problem
here's the
here's the issue remember the
deplorables are the common mans on both
sides of the trade
you have the ape army that is just a
collection of several million of people
throwing in money and and by buying and
holding these traditional companies okay
and the stock price goes up because they
refuse to sell the shorts that are the
naked shorts
all that money they're managing is
essentially pension fund money
and what they're doing is they're using
and they're doing this naked shorts
and using leverage to really not just
destroy the companies but to
speculate this is this is this is not
hedging is a natural part of wall street
to hedge certain long positions this is
not that
this is where you're in high speculation
to basically make a profit on destroying
companies and leaking information here's
where the rig game is
last summer steve cortez who's the great
guy over at newsmax and a trader for 30
years
he saw these meme stocks and last year
he does
thousands of trades a year he tried to
buy gamestop
right first time his life not not margin
but in
a an online account he had cash money in
first time in 30 years on wall street he
couldn't buy the stock
they were protecting the hedge funds
against the stock going up
so you couldn't and this is a big
controversial ramen you couldn't execute
the buy
which is in wall street sometimes you
can't sell because of restrictions but
hey anybody you want to stock boom
you got cash not leveraged boom you can
buy it this
is how the casino is rigged and it's
written this is why
this transcends politics because here
you have this ape army
of just everyday americans and they're
teaching each other they're teaching you
so i mean brittany avery was on she
sounded like a trader goldman sachs
woman's been in the stock since january
she's talking about dips and shoulders
and you know
and and they get naked options and the
la and the calls are coming i mean i'm
sitting there going wow
this is not bad where did she learn it
she learned it and they go online they
teach each other this is a community
and i'm telling you the charlie
gasparino
and all the wall street press the wall
street
seeking alpha has the the guy in the
short position who's sweating bullets
who writes the article
they are trying to force these guys to
sell for every host of reason to save
a citadel capital in the big highly
leveraged funds and this is why it's one
of the most
it's applied populism this is not people
talking about it
this is people doing it and i'm not
telling the audience to go buy the stock
what i definitely would do is seek out
this community
and find out more about it you will
learn more about practical finance if
you don't know anything about the stock
market if you don't know anything about
economics you don't know anything about
finance
i think these people will teach you and
they will teach you what the reality is
and this is still and you come from the
occupy movement i mean this is the
this is the problem we've had since the
crash the problem we've had since the
crash in 2008
is that the one percent has gotten it's
insane because obama is the most
progressive president in history
the solution at the time was to
basically blow up the balance sheet of
the federal reserve
increase assets and let all people own
stocks and real estate
just accu they went from 880 billion
dollars in the fed's balance sheet to
4.5 trillion
that money was infused in the system to
save the system
okay on the shoulders of the little guy
it was them paying for the bailouts it
was your taxes and also the negative
interest rate they want the interest
rates went to zero
zero interest rates kills the little guy
because you can never accumulate any
capital you don't get any interest on
your money market any savings account
it's destroyed this is why i say the
millennials are
nothing more than russian serfs they're
better educated you're in better shape
you have more access to information
you don't own anything and you're not
going to own anything and today
blackrock and blackstone are buying up
every house in the country because of
zero interest rates they're going to get
the upside of the assets
you're going to pay the rent they keep
saying in the davos oh just be a runner
don't need to own anything
you'll have no skin in the game you'll
con you're just be a serf
that's going to be a search let's expand
that you mentioned the seeking alpha
article i pulled it up
where it's it says an open letter to the
apes the stock market in reality
the original title the original title
was emotion may tell you to buy
reason will tell you to sell then once
you get all the way to the bottom as
steve mentioned i scrolled all the way
to the bottom and he says disclosure i
am
we are short amc i wrote this article
myself and it expresses my own opinions
i'm not receiving compensation for it
other than seeking alpha i have no
business relationship with any company
whose stock is mentioned in this article
additional disclosure
i have sold amc calls i also own mgic
mtg stock i briefly mentioned
he's against the wall first he sounds
like your father he's patting you on the
head and tell me about it then he gives
it then he's the voice of reason
it sounds so great at the end of it all
you want to do is get out of the stock
and you're right
and then you see gotta get out of the
sock honey we gotta dump it
so this is how the media tries to rub
off little guy
this these people they come in they
short a stock and then once
you know the apes come back and they
start saying hey we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna fight back
they you see all these articles come out
saying it's bad it's a bad idea don't
buy don't do it
cnbc doesn't even say the word naked
shorts but let me tell you something
else you mentioned blackrock
have you seen how many articles there
are right now saying millennials
don't buy a house or how many articles
say a recent poll says millennials hate
owning homes don't like it
don't like it this is the the great
reset and and build back better they the
party of davos if you go to davos the
world can i perform that commercial it
starts up by
we don't need to own anything and we're
going to be happier right you will owe
nothing
you will be happy you will own nothing
and you will be happier and then all of
a sudden
here's the thing you're paying for it i
want to go back to the great alex jones
he said it information warfare what this
is there's three types of warfare
as the chinese teaches an unrestricted
warfare there's information warfare
that which is includes cyber but
propaganda there's there's
economic warfare and there's kinetic
warfare guns bombs everything like that
and sun tzu teaches you hey i want to
defeat them before we get to kinetic
foreign devils what i want to do is
information and
economic warfare there is information in
economic warfare against the working
class
and middle class in the world today okay
and
this is why this ape army's bringing
that article is sophisticated
information warfare
psychologically it's very persuasive
both from an emotional point of view and
then at the end the reason point of view
you actually think your father your
your smart uncle is actually sitting
there going take the profit
sell the stock sell the stock because
the hedge funds are
jammed and then at the bottom full
disclosure oh i'm short that should be
at the top the disclosure should be
100 if it was fair it's a it's a rigged
casino the casino's rigged and their
friends make all the profits there's a
thing called arc archagus
that was his family office the new scam
this family office
imploded a couple weeks ago making all
these trades gunning wong
but it was the banks there's 20 billion
dollars of
losses by morgan stanley by ubs
by no more securities billions and
billions of dollars okay
of all pension funds that's all the
deplorables money is wiped out reason
the latest scam they have the hedge
funds are virtually unregulated
the family offices are not are unreal
there's zero regulation
this is all the super wealthy we've
created what the revolution in 1776 was
against was a landed aristocracy
in the united kingdom in england we have
created a global
aristocracy that's purpose in life is to
make sure the little guy never gets off
the mat and they will use any type of
information economic warfare to do that
i want to go back something you
mentioned
you mentioned that i came from occupy
and it was and that's populist left and
that's true but the people that i used
to
that i know that uh i met during occupy
are
authoritarian establishment left now
they're no longer populist libertarian
left they're
absolutely toe the line for the fbi
support the feds support the war
the most i tweeted something i posted on
facebook too
i said the the greatest deradicalization
in the history of the united states
the activists left who used to oppose
the federal government who are
supporting the hackers who were
the best the best we've the best free
speech people in the world
the aclu are posting in support of the
fbi
the cia are saying it's it's wrong to
end the wars because it'll create a
power vacuum and i'm like wow
i said this this is this uh woman i know
she's she was part of the hacker
community not necessarily big hacker
herself but she was friends with all of
them
she was very active during occupy and
she posted when the feds
uh raided giuliani's apartment in office
he was like yay and i said
incredible to see you finally
recognizing what was wrong with your
radicalism
and supporting the the fbi and the
federal government the people of course
you were protesting quite literally for
five years
and they don't understand one one person
who went to prison
for hacking said well better they use it
on my opponents than me and i was like
so you're an authoritarian who likes the
use of governmental force to shut down
your rivals
i was like bro didn't you protest that
exact thing
weren't you one of the people like
championing julian assange and
complaining about his
uh unlawful detainment or i shouldn't
say unlawful because they certainly
claim it is but the unethical
amoral detainment of julian assange now
all of a sudden you're happy
the federal government just goes and
does whatever they want
i don't know what happened to these
people no lord acton told us about it
power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely this is about power
that's right it's about power they now
have power
and and here's the thing think back to
the 60s and 70s
the the new york times the the
washington post the great investigative
reporting against the corruption
in in the cia what was happening the ca
and the fbi
that led to the church commission all
the checks and balances we kind of had
in congress the special committees and
the ability to have the
the gang of eight and review all this
this all came from essentially
liberal or left center left or liberal
the bastions of liberal media
in the 60s and 70s that led to these
investigations that
should have been done and had to be done
those places today the new york times
and the
washington post are are the vanguard of
protection
of a national security apparatus i'm a
foreign naval officer my daughter went
to west point you know we
our whole family my kid brother that's
here today as a navy pilot all of us
served
we're the biggest guys are sitting there
going this apparatus is
out of control it's out of control
against every american
i i love this uh uh this i i wonder if
let me start over people have tried to
figure out what left and right means
in these in this day and age it
certainly meant something you know 20
years ago i guess maybe it didn't
uh during occupy it certainly did you
had the libertarian right you're the
libertarian left
wokeness came into occupy and really did
a number and destroying a lot of it
and i wonder if that was you know
intentional there's a comic we reference
where it's a
wealthy guy in a big office and there's
protesters saying occupy wall street
outside
he's on the phone and he goes introduce
identity politics that was one of the
big things that that really helped break
apart
the libertarians who showed up to occupy
wall street they leave as soon as this
stuff pops into place
but i wonder if there is a big uh if if
the issue is
populist versus elitist or authoritarian
versus libertarian these are core
components
i think it's populist versus elitist in
in nationalist versus globalist
the nation state is still the best way
to to to to
to have your to have you not just your
values but to have your basic rights
right but how about the religious
framework as well right
so if you look at the woke which is a
very large component of the
establishment
their moral framework is fascistic they
believe there is no objective truth
there is only power
it was it was uh the late david graber
who was one of the uh
key uh organizers of occupy wall street
who actually said this
he tweeted out big element of the left
today is that this fascistic belief
there's no truth but power
and so you look at the the uh
judeo-christian moral framework
which is far from perfect but there's a
lot of aspects of it like
blackstone's formulation rooted in the
story of adam gamora i bring this up i
don't want to riff too much on this but
i think
you know we try to figure out what left
and right means and it's hard to know
for
sure but i do think the biggest aspect
might just be
will you be honest and fair with someone
and and and their rights to
individualism
or do you think those in power should
wield it against anyone who would oppose
them
well i think that's what the globalists
i think the globalists are totally
materialistic and they prepare
that power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely and they
feel they have absolute power i think
everything on the cultural side are just
things a lot of things are just thrown
out there i'm still an economic and
financial power the
people that have that power actually
control things right and
they're trying to do other i think one
of the things that you saw what mao did
and the bolsheviks did to try to break
the traditional
family the key is to break the family
right you see that here with a lot
what happened here i think with what i
call cultural marxism is still to have
these struggle sessions to try to break
the nuclear family and to break that
just like mao that was the whole thing
of the cultural revolution
was to break that same thing with the
bolsheviks you you mentioned
uh we talked about this article from
seeking alpha where the guy says hey
you know you should sell your amc stocks
and then finally at the bottom he says
by the way i'm short which means he's
screwed and needs you to sell
and you said it was sophisticated
information warfare yes are you familiar
with fourth and fifth generational
warfare
yes so uh a big component being
information manipulation you mentioned
uh the art of war
you want to finish the war before you
get to kinetic you do manipulation
economics
and i'm so i'm just reigniting those
components
as i point to the book you have in front
of you the fourth turning yeah
and we we talked about this with i think
it was ben stewart right yes
the the fourth turning which is i
believe it's strass how generational
theory which
essentially is predicting that we are
about to enter we are entering a
a period of strife the winter season
which could mean a variation oh we're in
it
we're in it we're in the crisis yeah so
uh the crisis beginning beginning of the
crisis period we're past the unraveling
so i will uh i'll i'll just give people
a quick introduction and we'll jump into
it
80 years ago what did we what did we
have what do you mean after world war ii
and the in the
world war two yeah world war ii crisis
yes uh 80 years before world war ii
the the civil war eight years before the
american revolution that's right
so because of that people are saying hey
three for three right
what's what's the next big conflict so i
wonder is it is it this internal
conflict in the united states between
the establishment powers which which
does absolutely extend to international
interest for sure but you've got the
culture war here
and then you also have the conflict brew
with china
which is on the horizon taiwan they just
flew 28
warplanes the most ever into the
taiwanese defense
zone in the air and uh what's it gonna
be is it neither yeah can they see them
you should get and i'll raise it up a
little bit and i recommend everybody
read this book
right just just it's very dense this is
not a beach read
okay this is a very dense book but it is
worth struggling with
and working yourself through it's a real
thing to read books today and not just
stuff online
so get that straw somehow it's it's very
uh i i
as soon as i heard about it and got it
it and it's been very um
helpful for me as a framework it's not
perfect like any theory is but it talks
about different generations and every
generation
kind of raises the other differently but
if you look back in american history
from the revolution to the civil war to
the great depression world war
ii to today it has a certain pattern to
it and one of the things that people
particularly the news business those
people i see that are the always ahead
of the curve
understand pattern recognition pattern
recognition
these guys clearly saw it the um no
i think today i think we're hurtling
towards a couple of crises
one is obviously a global financial
crisis that i think could
make everything else before us uh look
like uh you know child's play
the other there's a massive geopolitical
crisis remember
you go back to classic geopolitics
makenda right now on the eurasian land
mass
which american foreign policy since 1914
is to make sure that no power or
combinations of power control the
eurasian land mass
because the world island which the
western hemisphere is kind of a island
off of the world island the world island
the pivoted that central asia and those
spots control the world now you have
china
with its partners pakistan iran turkey
and russia right and we kind of forced
russia over that we had every
opportunity to break it off
they are now working almost in concert
right almost with one belt
one road also but everything is focused
around getting off the u.s
dollar getting off the us dollars the
prime reserve currency and the swift
system as the system that ties it
together
they're looking to work in the concert
and in their controlling the eurasian
landmass will lead us to a
kinetic war in the south china sea or on
the border of india or somewhere
along those fissure points unless we are
wise enough and smart enough to start
acting like a great power along with our
allies
and as long as we continue to act like
children and our leadership act like
children
and to allow the chinese communist party
and in the party of davos
to infiltrate every aspect of capital
markets wall street our global
corporations all of it
you know information warfare and
economic warfare who have every ability
to take this thing down and to do it in
90 days
yet the elites in our country refuse to
do it and it's the little guy this is
the just like in
every other war it's the little guy
that's going to go over there
it's a little guy's kids are going to go
over there they're the ones going to be
buried in foreign battlefields their
taxes the ones are going to pay for it
they're going to have the financial
strife and that's why it's time for
populist left and populist right that
are populist and nationalist
to me to transcend politics see where we
agree put this together
realign the politics in this country and
we can control the country for a hundred
years
so i um i'm curious because uh we had
the american revolution which was an
international conflict essentially
then we had a civil war civil war was an
internal conflict and we had another
external conflict i don't totally agree
with that you don't think so no it was
also part of a remember
lincoln and these guys were also
nationalists obviously slavery drove it
but slavery drove it
let's leave the moral issues aside which
were horrific it was also the thing of
economics and in
in the exploitation of african americans
for free labor
right and lincoln these guys were
nationalists they were hardcore
nationalists remember lincoln in his
term
uh built the transcontinental railroad
right past the homestead act
which allowed free land and set up the
land grant universities which allowed
the common man's kids actually go and
get
agriculture and technical thing so these
guys were nationalists they had a
they had a nationalist perspective and
the southern plantation aristocracy were
part
of a globalized system with the united
kingdom that they're even thinking of
going to brazil in south america and
start a slave empire down there
that would be part of a global empire
basically essentially tied back to the
british if they could get around the
thing of hey
we're gonna have slaves drive this just
like the slaves in china remember
the slave labor of china drives the
entire system today we still have
slavery
the slavery in china drives the system
today but what i mean to say is the
fighting was internal
the fighting was here yes then we had
another international conflict overseas
so i wonder if in this fourth turning
are we going to be experiencing an
internal conflict like we had uh the
boston globe reported
yes that uh john podesta said if biden
doesn't win
the west coast should secede from the
union 48 states were involved in this
lawsuit that got thrown out eventually
and so uh i'll put it this way um
we see the stuff with china uh russia
obviously south china sea is big
we just had uh russian war games off the
coast of uh 300 miles west of hawaii
freaked everybody out
you've got uh president biden which many
people are concerned he's not up to
actually
defending taiwan or being
commander-in-chief at a time of serious
war
silicon valley west yeah with the chips
we don't have a choice
right right exactly forget the moral
thing you don't defend you think you've
got to slow down and get in your f-100
truck right now or your refrigerator
cause a chip shortage
let's let the ccp take over charlie won
so uh you mentioned
the people who have been successful been
good at pattern recognition and so uh
a lot of my success came from my ability
to be at the right place at the right
time during the occupy era during the
vice when i was for vice
i would be like here's the place we need
to be i'd fly there and then boom news
would explode
i'd happen to be there be able to film
it and that's why i got accused of being
a fed half the time because they were
like how does tim know to be in these
places for these big stories it's like
no i just recognized all the news that
was bubbling up and i went and checked
it out
for the past several years i've been i
would say bullish on
some kind of civil war be it the culture
war
culminating to a very serious economic
crisis it's been called a cold civil war
or even a hot crisis
between political factions i think a lot
of people like bill maher for instance
he said you couldn't have this because
the mason-dixon line would go through
you know grandma's kitchen but that's
because he has no understanding of
civil wars internationally he's he's
fixed on some american idea where states
fought states
and not say spain where you had regions
that just diverted into you know were
dominated by certain ideologies
so i've had a lot of people tell me i'm
wrong every step of the way
from the start of the street battles
from even occupy water that i
experienced into
the battle for berkeley where you'd
antifa proud boys and it got
particularly bad where we're still
seeing some of these battles i don't
know if it'll escalate beyond that
but the the culture war the ideological
rift the wokeness the anti-woke is is at
the highest point of government
it's in the military it's in the federal
government it's in the presidency
it's in the opposition of the presidency
it's in congress you've got
uh woke policies you know
trainings happening in federal
government and then i still have people
say to me
tim you're wrong there will not be a
civil war could never happen here
and now we're at the point where they're
still saying it and then i mentioned
january 6th like if
these people on the left say tim's crazy
for thinking this i not now i just
respond with
uh on january 6 a bunch of uh right-wing
people stormed into the capital
a lot of them bumbled in mind you the
cops opened the doors but uh what would
you say about that
and then they go quiet i bring all this
up just to see what your thoughts are on
the potential for
you know civil war if that's going to be
our our our fourth turning or if it's
going to be international conflict
i think it's a combination of both and
look on the civil war aspect
it doesn't need to get it doesn't need
to get violent i think we're in a pre if
you go back and study history
we're in a nastier uh more vitriolic
time than before the civil war go back
and say
the 1850s how long until someone gets
caned in congress well
okay this is right here this is this is
my point and that was pretty of a pretty
violent time
right a pretty violent time and the
passions ran very hot
you're in that aspect today but we do
not need to devolve it in fact to me the
suckers play is to try to get violent
this is what i was always against you
don't need the insurrection act
we're winning we're winning the people
in this country are now
awakening to the fact of what the
economic reality is and how they've been
particularly republicans
remember all these world corporations in
the social media corporations
that are shutting down republicans
across the board
the last 30 or 40 years of republican
orthodoxy has been given deregulation
give them tax cuts
the reason i fought the tax cuts
president trump and his tax cuts worked
out very well but certain aspects of i
wanted to tax the wealthy
i wouldn't increase the tax rate to 44
percent number one i made the starling
thing
they don't pay taxes anyway and last
week we saw uh you know and merrick
garland
just remember joe biden's attorney
general merrick garland says my number
one priority
is to get the leaks of the 25
billionaires
that were put out there and by the way
mitch mcconnell comes out and says it's
my
number one priority too mary graham says
this let's let's but
because that story went down the memory
hole you didn't see story after story in
the new york times about that you didn't
see story after story
and even the conservative media you
didn't see story in a story on on
on cnbc right 25 billionaires that have
control of i don't know
500 billion dollars in assets at least
that are reported
right half a trillion dollars 25 over
the last five years have paid a
combination less than 15 billion dollars
in taxes
that's what i said raise the upper rate
because they don't pay taxes now
and they can avoid eventually which is
going to be the tax on the assets
because that's going to come somebody's
got to pay for this if we're going to
have this level of spending
you've got three ways to pay for it
either sell the bonds to japan and china
right you either raise taxes or or you
or you print money there's one you could
grow out of it but we're stuck in
in a low growth survey you know
environment because we're so overspent
so now there's 30 trillion dollars you
know obama because of the
what he did to the federal reserve and
the zero inch rate we had a 10 trillion
down obama's watch
and we've added another i think a
trillion dollar or four trillion
two or three trillion dollar trumps and
now we just exploded under biden and
it's it's nowhere
it's not stopping now they got this
modern modern terry theory there's a new
theory about it
but hey that's why everybody's running
to crypto right yep that's why
everybody's running back to gold and
silver
that's why people are prepping i brought
some financial times and every time you
pick it up
it's the global apparatus regulatory
apparatus has one focus of mind how do i
crush
crypto how do i make sure how do i make
sure it's not an alternative
store of value like gold and silver are
yep they don't want you to have an
alternative this is the bank of
international settlements out of
out of switzerland basically that's
running that it's also yes that
it's also the central banks it's the
bank of tokyo it's the bank of england
it's the federal reserve they're all
going to regulate it and now
you can't do these just using blockchain
you can't just be private they want to
get into all the
all the checks and balances the ccp is
shutting down all the all the farmers
themselves to make it tougher what they
want to do
is to they see the ability of crypto and
look crypto's not i disagree with
president trump it's not a scam
there's 2.1 trillion dollars of dollars
in the world trading every day
right using because you have to convert
to dollars to do all trans there's 2.1
trillion dollars out there
okay every day doing transactions all
the world i think there's now
2.2 trillion dollars of crypto so there
are scams in it
but it's clearly an alternative that p
and it's
definitely a alternative store value and
may
it may not feel like that to bitcoin
holders today when you're down at 30 000
but but
you know it's but it's for guys that
bought it at five it is and it's still
an alternative when you look at these
other cryptocurrencies you've got to
take your trade
but the central apparatus wants to take
that option away from you again if you a
central authority messing things up
this is not financial advice i'm just
saying um if an individual
put a portion of their paycheck into
bitcoin every week
like it was a savings account they would
not be upset today
because i bought i bought bitcoin in
november
oh no oh bitcoin fell to 30 000 rgs
imagine if you told someone in november
when it was at 13 000
that it was going to crash to 30 and
people would panic they would laugh and
be like oh buying some right now
i just i i it's to me it's almost like a
savings here's what everybody will do
why does the system when when you're
educated they teach everything these
public schools etc even the catholic
schools christian schools but the
particularly public schools in any
college
you never learn anything about basic
finance no you never do
they want you to be illiterate of you
have to get in the world think of your
life in your early 20s or 30s when
you're on your own your
everything's about hey i got to make i
got to pay the credit card i got to pay
rent
you're thrown into the world with no
they want you to be
financially illiterate the power of the
ape army
and what people are doing i'm not saying
buy meme stocks and i'm not saying buy
crypto you know what you need to do
it's time now to act like an adult and
say hey guess what everything they're
telling me is a lie
i'm going to go find out for myself i
want to do my own research
i want to sit there and i want to i want
to find it i want to learn about this i
have to learn
you have to you have to become
intellectually
financially independent to make your own
choices not just financially this brings
me to the question that uh that i had to
bring up
um doing the research for yourself you
you just said tax the rich i i believe
um but i thought you were far right
and believed in deregulation and the
billionaires at least that's what the
media tells everybody right
you've come out multiple times saying
these people are getting away with not
paying anything you're getting ripped
off
so the wall street journal dumped out in
the summer 17 i wanted to raise
to president trump i said we should
raise tax on the wealthy to 44
and on the corporations as they bring
this cash back from overseas
right it ought to be tax less if it's
putting capital equipment and plant and
because we must rebuild the
manufacturing base of this country for
the american people
and if you put it in detroit or st louis
or baltimore inner cities you get a
bigger tax cut
every piece of capital in this country
that goes into the manufacturing of
putting the capital equipment to build
fourth industrial manufacturing jobs
is going to increase the ability of the
working-class family look here's the
goal
we want the ability i'm not saying women
have to do this but we want the ability
to get back to the 50s
where one wage earner can have a family
a wife
and children or a husband and children
and they don't
have to work unless they want to work we
can get back to that
it's no law of meta there's no second
law of thermodynamics that says we have
to have this free trade that would
we centered factories all over the world
that we basically put all the burden on
the american
the little guy the american citizen for
all the wars
all the taxes everything's put on his
shoulders his or her shoulders
it doesn't have to be that you should
have a special deal if you're an
american citizen right
and that deal deals with let's have a
tax policy
that rewards labor and work not just
simply capital
because right now it's out of balance
let's get back to a balance
i'm a capitalist i'm not some left-wing
socialist but i gotta tell you i say
this all the time
unless we reform capitalism it this
thing's going away
it's very fast it's interesting if the
money you held got higher tax rates but
the money you make
does has a lower tax rate until you hold
it for like a set amount of time and
then it's the tax rate starts to go up
the longer you hold it let's talk
about negative interest rates
speculation but here's the thing is that
the wealthy they have
this is the if you go back and look at
the 24 people that are the wealthiest in
the nation
they don't pay the pay the taxes of
bloomberg and buffett is like
0.11 because they have all these tax
accountants
looking for every deal in the world that
the system
gives them the supposedly for investment
but system gives them
to avoid taxes i will uh
counter with this though taxing them
just puts the money into the government
and it's like the government is free
from corruption
well first of all it doesn't totally put
the money first up we've got to pay if
we're going to have a government to
provide these services and has a one
trillion dollar and that's what we have
one trillion dollar
defense budget because you add up all
the net all the intelligence and add in
all the
areas where they put it into other
departments it's a trillion dollars a
year if we're going to continue to spend
like this
somehow it's got to be paid for i'm all
for cutting it
but still the wealthy because of their
benefits remember think about it
it's like the environment back in the in
the in in the 60s or 70s before we had
environmental laws
they had this thing called the commons
right because the effluent you know the
hudson river you
you could was filthy the air in la you
couldn't see through
because to dump everything didn't have
any charge to it and then the people had
a thing to actually to start to charge
for effluents you had the
clean air act and all these things and
it got and those people say oh the
libertarian said you can't regulate but
the water got cleaner the air got
cleaner president trump says i love
clean water i love clean air hey it all
got better
why because the commons we have the same
thing here when people say
well steve we have the most robust
liquid capital markets in the world in
the stock market
that's all because of the little guy
it's because it's
civic society upon the shoulders of the
working class and middle class in this
country
everything rest okay the cops the
teachers the nurses
the people that build the the coach
little league to build the churches
that civic society of america is what
provides for the safety of investment
that's why the whole world wants to come
here and invest their dollars it's on
the shoulders
all my point is hey let's still give a
little something for the effort
right i'm not some radical socialist but
if we don't shift
a little more to the working men and
women in this country
right and that's what the apes are doing
they ain't waiting for regulation you
know what they're doing they're saying
hey you're destroying good american
companies
it's a rigged game how about this buy
and hold
right and if that if you're sold this
stock short and it goes up
tough that's tough luck we're going to
crush you and they're going to crush
these headphones on the way to the
corruption
they're going to get to the casino and
they're going to tear the casino down
this is uh
occupy wall street 2.0 it's got a lot of
people on the left younger people
democratic socialists
cheering for it it's got people on the
right trump supporters
populist uh right-wing individuals lots
of veterans
a lot of veterans it's amazing to hear
you know the things you're saying about
the working class about taxing the rich
because i wonder why it is that we don't
see more of the populists left
agreeing finding out where they agree
and what they can target to change
and changing it i think they're i think
the populist
i've always said a third of the the
bernie let's go back to 16.
and my you know work on populism with
breitbart beforehand
16 was very simple the reason trump won
is that the american working men and
women in certain middle class people
rejected the managed decline of our
country
by an elite of both parties it's wall
street it's the global corporations
it's the uniparty and here's what the
thing is they're comfortable with that
managed decline because they're making
more money on the way down
than we made on the way up okay so it's
the managed decline of our country by
the elites and that's what kind of the
trump was
the middle finger to that that's right
and that's and that i think more
populous the one-third of the bernie
people
particularly now after two cycles you
didn't win
right because the fight was not the
fight of the people was there
but the fight of the candidates itself
was not there to take on the neoliberal
neocons of which the the clinton
apparatus was in the central apparatus
of the republican party well one of the
problems i see now
you know i mentioned this earlier on in
the show friends of mine from occupy
wall street
now supporting the federal government
the fbi the establishment
they've abandoned the populist left and
it's just basically tribalism
if if it's bad for the right they'll
cheer for it they're not interested in
improving things
i wonder if a big aspect of it is
they're young and inexperienced and
their whole world is just my side is the
right side and we better win by any
means necessary
or if it's just authoritarians who have
manipulated people seized power and
while there certainly were populists at
occupy wall street many
many of which i found out later switched
and voted for trump you got jack
murphy's book democrat to deplorable
a lot of these younger people who are in
the early 20s just support the
establishment and will vote for whatever
the establishment wants
i'm thinking about the liberal economic
order they built it after world war ii
to prevent world war
iii the british and the americans were
like we're gonna set up military bases
all over the world
and they basically did prevent world war
iii although you could say now maybe the
system is vestigial and it's ready to be
changed or ripped down or
maybe the whole world could create a
world police or something but people see
the value of this fascistic militarism
that's prevented world war
iii and so there is a kind of a
dissonance like
how do we transition away from this let
me go back there for a second i actually
think we had world war three
and uh we won by information in economic
warfare and we didn't have to go we had
to go kinetic sometimes within korea or
or these in vietnam and other places but
we won because we took down
the central communist apparatus of the
soviet union
right we defeated it and i remember in
1989
within a few months of the berlin wall
coming down he had tiananmen square
in tiananmen square we had a moment in
time when the elites in the united
states
having take having reagan's let's we win
they lose having the collapse of the
soviet union
we could have taken down the whole thing
the ccp would have collapsed that's
where they were in panic
and 30 days after we propped them up
general skullcroft went over from bush
43
of bush 41 went over there and basically
made a deal with the ccp that we're
going to support you we're going to
orient them because they saw the ability
of the chinese model right they always
thought they could change china
democrats but they really bought into
the economic model where china would be
the central
apparatus of manufacturing those jobs
that all get shipped over
and you essentially use they say cheap
labor slave
labor in china lao baijin old hundred
names would be slave labor
and that would support this
international system that's not a
conspiracy
them's facts okay and you can this whole
system
is predicated upon that we had we
actually won world war three
by information and kinetic warfare and
we gave it away and that's why all the
guys just said the end of history and
all this nonsense
forgot the fact that we then went to
this kind of global globalization
right predicated around the slave labor
of china that exported deflation
and inability to raise prices but
particularly in a ability to raise wages
because you've always got excess
capacity by the state-owned industries
of china
and that's why working people throughout
the world have suffered in the united
states the central
economic point we haven't had an
increase real wages
have not changed except for 19 when
trump had it since 1972-73
working look around anywhere in this
country it's clearly not as good as it
was back
30 and 40 years ago because you've had a
huge deterioration
of of of working class people ability to
have
high value added high paying
manufacturing
jobs during uh trump uh trump's
administration in 2019 particularly
the economy was great jim cramer's had
the best number of numbers of our lives
there was something i found pretty
hilarious the left is advocated for a
bunch of things like
day work week or you know less hours per
day
or more vacation time paternal leave
you know maternal weather otherwise and
they want this through regulation
the government should snap their fingers
right down boom make it happen
under trump without regulation it
started to happen
there were several stories i think it
was potbelly sandwiches announced a
four-day work week vacation time
we started seeing that happen in so many
different companies
people were making more money when we
were buying furniture for the first
uh studio setup for this show i went to
a furniture store and the lady told me
she she had never made as much money in
her life as she did in 2019
this is the beginning of 2020 and i
heard the same thing with the contractor
who is doing work
on the house to help us build this he's
like this best year of my life last year
so all of these things came about
through economic policy under trump but
i'm wondering
some people have argued it was trump
just spending like crazy which was
creating an artificial bump in the
system that made everyone feel good but
wasn't actually fixing things
curious what your thoughts were with uh
look there's there's a keynesian aspect
of that you know you had you had
spending and you had tax cuts at the
same time so
double whammy but you also had
restrictions on immigration
right which is a big thing for working
for working-class people particularly
non-skilled labor remember it's the
chamber of commerce as the republicans
want all that
the democrats want the votes and the
republicans want the cheap labor okay
but also at the higher end i'm a
restrictionist and i also am the leader
of the of one of the leaders of the
freedom movement the chinese people and
i'm the
chairman of the of the republican hindu
coalition
right so i love modi i love the
nationalism in india i got a lot of
close friends but
and i chose it but i'm i'm a
restrictionist and the reason is we need
american citizens
to get high tech high if you turn the
entire
education system over to stem in grade
school right
you need to be able to have
african-american and latino
and hispanic people get into the
engineering schools and get jobs in
silicon valley and get jobs in the
fourth industrial revolution
manufacturing jobs this whole thing
we're gonna be a service economy
is a joke one of the biggest things
coming out of here now you see is what's
nine million jobs and they can't phone
from the service economy
one-third of the jobs last for the biden
thing the disastrous
job numbers were bartenders and and and
uh and waiters i used to be a bartender
in college i said but people don't see
it as a career
one of the good things you see people
hesitant to come back one of the reasons
is hey
i don't know if i just want to go back
to that grind that has no future to it
can't i do something else that hopefully
is the entrepreneur
people want to start businesses but it's
also we must return to become a
manufacturing superpower
anybody that sells you any corporation
any advertisement any politician that
sells you
that we can be a service economy is
lying to you
is lying to you you're always going to
work for surf like wages
right you're always going to work like
surf like wages until we return
to a manufacturing superpower i'm a
hardcore protectionist
i'm hardcore tariffs and protectionists
and not just that i wouldn't happy talk
around these corporations about you are
you gonna take your capital and you're
gonna move it overseas
no you're not until we understand that
manufacturing jobs are not being
outsourced
that capital and investors capital that
belongs here in the united states of
america
it's protected and the civic society has
built it we're not communist we're not
socialists
but this ability for this is my problem
with the libertarians they see the free
flow of capital in the free flow of
labor and open borders and open capital
markets
i say not so fast we're a country with
an economy we're not an economy first
this whole thing of this austrian school
of economics and all these guys talking
about
you know it's like it's like a lot of
guys in the right now saying oh it's
just free markets of blackstone and
blackrock are buying up all the housing
stock
no it's not we're not we can't have a
system where you buy up all the housing
stock and have the millennials just rent
it back so you're paying your interest
payment
and you get the zero interest rate you
get the juice on the asset increase
you can't have a country like that
you're not going to have firemen you're
not going to have police officers you're
not going to have military to protect
you
you can't do this if people don't get
skin in the game
and i mean real ownership so they can
sit there and go this is mine
i can pass it on to my kids you're gonna
have a system that's going to collapse
you should have been on day one
in new york at occupy wall street see
what happened was
in the early few days a lot of what
you're saying was what was being said
i met an elderly couple they must have
been in their 60s with a big ol american
flag talking about how we got screwed
over by the elites how the big banks
working us off how we were footing the
bill
and there were a lot of people there but
there was no sustained leadership
what happened was these kind of people
are old they have
work to do so they eventually go home
but the trust
fund college kids with nothing but time
on their hands
and driven by woke ideology
they would come down and they would
organize the meetings every single day
and over time this weeded out a lot of
the conversations a lot of things that
you you were saying
i feel like and maybe it's just a
wishful thinking that if you
or someone like you were there on day
one someone who was gonna
actually say the things you're saying
and maintain that as the conversation
then the woke takeover of occupy never
would have happened and that would have
very much changed the trajectory of the
past 10 years when i was at occupy
in the first week i met luke ridkowski
do you know luke he's uh were you was it
luke and anarchist
yeah technically capitalist you love him
he's a right anarchist this is his
company we are yeah we are changed we
have one of the show every so often he's
up at pork fest the free state project
i met him down there and he's he's right
libertarian and i was left libertarian
but it was very much like the elites are
screwing us the system and all that
stuff
i remember i was having a conversation
with some people one day and they
announced they were implementing
progressive stack that meant if you want
to speak at any of these meetings
and you were white you're out you're a
man you're out
if you were lgbtq you'd have to announce
that to the entire group and out
yourself
if you would like to speak if you were a
man that
shut everything down people started
leaving people who were interested in
pushing back against the corruption
started crying i i knew one guy who was
saying a lot of things you were saying
he left crying and never came back then
you look at where
that movement has gone since then and
you know look i i supported bernie
sanders in 2015 and 16.
why what did bernie sanders say to
vox.com
in the interview with ezra klein i am
not for open borders that is a koch
brothers proposal
they want free labor and i don't support
that what did bernie sanders then say
when he's in the debate stage in in 2019
2020
how many of you are in favor of
decriminalizing border crossings they'll
raise their hand how many of you want
free health care for nonsense they all
raise their hand
that's not what the left was about
remember the battle the battle in
seattle
1999 was it i was looking i remember it
i learned about it only through occupy
wall street
they were they were opposing the world
trade organization something happened
wto yeah these people came in during
occupy
and because they were young exuberant
and had nothing better to do
easily took it over and it's a bummer
because there were a lot of people
i see i see a lot of people from occupy
who wouldn't become trump supporters
trump voters
a lot of people sort of supported bernie
then went to support trump
and a lot of those people are still in
the same place
as not necessarily left not really right
but just for the people
populist support manufacturing support
the working class
and we're being torn apart by a culture
war we're being torn apart by ideology
this whole thing about critical race
theory
and because of that it's fascinating
i'll see people on the left
who completely agree with every
everything you said about increasing
taxes on the wealthy
and helping the working class but then
they'll come out and defend critical
race theory something that
we for instance absolutely oppose i
oppose because
i come from a second generation i'm
second generation mixed race in my
family
and that ideology identitarianism would
rip apart
you know the way our family the way we
live so i absolutely have to to oppose
that
i feel like that whole battle has
has made it impossible for the left and
right to come together maybe on purpose
it started around occupy wall street it
split everybody up and now when you see
left and right populists agreeing on
core economic issues
they can't agree on these critical race
theory questions they're not going to
come together you know what i mean i
think enough
can agree on the basic economics that we
can transcend this and actually can take
i think you'll see a realignment the key
is like look at the rio grande valley
look at these look at adult look these
are heart that's the most heart scrabble
part of this country
is 85 percent hispanic working class
hispanic
very culturally conservative but more
importantly they understand that open
borders is crushing them
these are people that understand i'm an
american citizen i deserve a deal that
protects me
and gives me a shot at a good paying job
eventually
if i work hard i mean look at let's go
to mr floyd about and i say this all the
time about
george floyd and and i don't want to
talk about the crime that's committed
against him that's a different topic but
i'll say let's look at his life
right when he died he had ccp virus he
had covert 19
he was on fentanyl on opioids right and
he didn't have a great job
because all the manufacturing jobs
shipped overseas think of what george
floyd's life would have been
if we had had a manufacturing base he
would be a supervisor or a foreman at a
at a factory or a junior management he'd
be closing up his
uh opening up his summer home to go
fishing up in the lake country in
minnesota
with his second home up there a little
cabin he could sure
if he if he didn't it didn't have the
the open the opioids that shipped in by
the chinese communist party through the
cartels in mexico
across open borders with everybody
making money on the way up and the huge
profits on that
to poison him to poison him and no
opportunity for a job
and to top it all off the chinese
communist party
virus that the elites in the in the
scientific priesthood
has basically helped fund and helped do
he had the ccp covet 19 virus in him he
had the virus in him had fentanyl in him
he didn't have access to a great job
because all the great manufacturing jobs
are shipped off look that's the track
that's the greek
tragedy to me of george floyd is that he
was in that position that day and by the
way let's talk about the fake 20.
well that's also the ccp and we know
that these foreign entities are putting
out this fake money all the time with
the opioids
to do it that was what the the
counterfeit bill was every aspect of his
life
driven by geopolitics that led to that
i'll issue one clarification
i think lab leak theory makes the most
sense we don't have any hard
confirmation
but you saw john stewart's rant for the
longest time
you know all last year it was you get
banned if you brought it up
now all of a sudden the mainstream media
is saying it even fauci himself is
saying he's not convinced that the virus
is naturally occurring
you had the emails that came out from
fauci from fauci's
own email account where you can see some
scientists saying they believe it was
engineered
but i'll always christian anderson at
scripps on january 31st yeah pretty
early in the process
absolutely jon stewart and this is the
power of jon stewart
he said he put it and look at colbert's
ridiculous response a full meltdown
this shows you a hack that's a political
hack now versus a master that was zen
master
the way he did that with the humor but
also
in his grill that you know how dare you
try to question it's obvious and
remember
let's talk about information warfare
don't buy
the concept or the nomenclature of lab
leak because what they want you to do is
think that hey
at worst case it leaked out of a lab
while they're
you know they had the bats there and the
bachelor this was
man enhanced this was gain of function
they took these they they took these
basic viruses and they weaponized them
they powered them up
when they should not have been doing it
it should have been authorized it should
have been
done they shouldn't they weren't
supervised we know that from the cables
that came back from the wuhan from our
guys in the state department
early on this is not a lab leak because
they want you to say labley because they
still want you to say just came from a
bat
this was powered up it was there was
gain of function research
at the wuhan lab yes fauci was providing
funding to ecohealth alliance which was
used for gain of function yes we now
know that google was involved in
providing wuhan linked
don't say this you're going to get
banned this is this is a boxer this is
this is you're going to get banned well
now we know now we know google
the whole time had their hand in it no
conflict of interest but i'll just say
one thing
we uh however we get there we do not yet
have hard confirmation that it is
true that it was uh here's what we have
hard confirmation of
we have hard confirmation that there is
no evidence
zero evidence that it came from a cave
in the laotian border
it traveled one if you've ever been to
china traveled 1 000 miles
from basically southern china lake ocean
border to
to to a wet market right and with the
thousands and tens of thousands of
villages through there
we don't have one farmer or one animal
or one sickness
we have nothing until it gets to wuhan
and there they said it was in a wet
market but they they they took the wet
market and got all the evidence out of
there so they won
so what we do have hard evidence is
there's nothing on there's no counter
theory to this so let me uh
we have this from nature.com a news
guard certified source as you can see
here 100 out of 100
animal sales for muhammad markets
immediately prior to the code pandemic
and they note in this study no bats and
no pangolins were sold the guardian also
reported this
so i'm trying to be very careful because
i know that censorship's a real issue
yes
uh that's why john stewart comes out
says
now he went over the top with it like
it's the seas yelling
and and colbert's response was when you
start working for ron johnson that's the
best you got that's insane
that's the best you guys that's the best
you got for me based on all of the
evidence we have so far this is the most
likely outcome
but i want to i don't want to say it's
definitive because
it's science and youtube will you know
well let me say that there's also
many intelligence services and sherry
marxism there's some great investigative
reports there's a lot of intelligence
services
from throughout the world that are all
on top of this and dr li min yang is a
defector
i my group non-profit group at the time
helped get her out
she is and people say well you know her
reports leave the reports aside
she's a fact witness a fact witness she
was at this
she was at the oversight lab in hong
kong
as one of the senior lab scientists
because she was in the mainland she was
ordered by the lab and she has it on
wechat to make contact
with beijing cdc on the 31st of december
of 2019 about a sars
breakout in wuhan china and she's got
the text of what they were told
at the time do you remember the uh
research paper that came out from i
think it was the south china university
yes uh where it is the the the author
said that
uh some of the researchers were peed on
by bats or bitten by them
now what's funny is that story was
retracted that that study was retracted
they took it down said it's not true and
i remember i covered it early on saying
this is interesting because there was a
lot of questions coming out even the
washington post entertained lab leaked
theory at the time
then the study gets retracted that you
know ccp says it's not true it was wrong
and and we all roll our eyes like oh
okay
these guys are all in camps now what do
we get from the wall street journal only
recently
three individuals from the wuhun
institute of virology were hospitalized
for some of these symptoms and they were
doing research on bets we now know from
nature.com from the scientific study as
reported by the guardian as well
that they weren't selling bats or
pangolins in the wet market so
as the best as we can say let me say
something about the wall street journal
that's another cover the wall street
journal financial times are nothing but
the tip sheets for the globalist
that's a cover everybody but everybody
in the intelligence community
everybody's following this new knew
about that story and knew what happened
this is no big and they that they
reported and it's also this huge
revelation
maybe we have to reconsider the lab
league because now
why is that they're looking because they
understand
that all roads lead to wuhan in a
biological
weapons program okay the ccp has had
four opportunities to say hey
we've signed off on the biological
weapons treaty and we're not doing
anything in these labs
right yet we know that the pla it
runs the the wuhan lab okay that
everything there is part of a biological
weapons program
when it got out of control they thought
they was getting out of control
the major the female major generals sent
down to ube province and wuhan to take
command
about the third week of january when
they quarantined it was this female
major general her job in the pla
biological warfare
right they went down they knew they had
a problem talk to the guys at fort
dietrich i mean this is kind of an open
this is why it's such a clown show
that this is an open secret among the
people that have focused on this
throughout the world you can't hide it
anymore
and for liabilities and everything else
you're going to see the mainstream media
and all these guys saying
even found you know i was always
open-minded well no brother you were not
open-minded
i'm i'm just wondering why it is that
all of a sudden the mainstream media is
just
saying okay lab league i mean you guys
because their lawyers are telling them
hey we got a big problem
you've been shutting down a tim pool
you've been shutting down guys on
twitter you've been shutting down guys
on facebook you're not having any
conversations
about either therapeutics or you're not
having any conversations about
what this is think about if we had had
an adult conversation remember we
started war room pandemic
on january 23rd right how did stay back
because i know china i've lived there
and i'm part of the this this
opposition group with miles grove we're
up there when
getting ready for our annual broadcast
that we do every year for for uh
lunar new year for chinese new year and
of course the first day
before that they're going to have the
big signing ceremony in the white house
in the east wing on the trade deal
so we're sitting there and then
afterwards it's kyle bass and bill gertz
i mean super hardcore
you know anti-ccp guys we're all going
to be part of this traditional three-day
broadcast
and miles gross tells us oh well we're
not doing the broadcast this year and i
go why he says well
they're going to shut down wuhan and ube
there's a sars breakout
and they're not going to have chinese
new years and i go they're not going to
change it what do you mean they're not
going to have
they've cancelled it i said when's the
last time that kansas said never we've
been around for 40 000 years we've
always had it that's why i said
this is a big deal so when i first
started hearing a lot of these
stories about the censorship you know
they were saying don't repeat these
things about
lab league they said trump was racist
for calling it the china virus and all
that stuff and trump even said kung flu
my my instinct and a lot of people
brought up is that the establishment
elites are very favorable to china they
want to protect them
now we have this inversion where the
narrative is actually oh
the mainstream media is actually saying
yes lab leak and i'm wondering if
the administration deep state whatever
you want to call it
do they want war with china why is it
that
last year they didn't they didn't care
was it because they hated trump so much
they wanted to look bad
is it this year they're they're hoping
that these conversations can lead to
public
okay we are at war with china they're at
war with us
they're an information war they're an
economic war they've infiltrated every
institution in this nation
our political class wall street they own
wall street they're in partnership with
wall street
global corporations china the chinese
communist party not the chinese people
and not the nation of china a
transnational criminal organization
that's just like the soviets just like
the nazis just like the fascists
they're all criminal organizations
they're at war with the united states
and they've been at war with the united
states
information war and economic war
remember there's three parts of it they
don't want to fight kinetic
because they think the foreign devils
can beat them but guess what they're
getting to the point if they have to in
the south china sea or if they have to
in taiwan
they're going to come a day that they're
going to say and that day is not too far
off
well stand up biden is doing the minimum
he has to because he's getting jammed up
by working-class americans other people
are saying the chinese communist party
is the problem here
and if we can't step back as adults and
say this
was an act of war whether they purposely
released it or even if it inadvertently
leaked
what they did in the days and weeks to
follow peter navarro walks you through
it
they exacerbated the problem they were
having their citizens buy up ppe in
various countries and ship it back to
china 100 percent
100 by by the way one to make it worse
they're number two
to have it use it strategically later on
to say come with us
also they were working on a vaccine dr
lee man yang says in 10
000 years and the chinese have been very
advanced medically
they have never come up with a vaccine
how the sudden they pop up with a
vaccine
for regardless of his efficacy and it
ain't great
how long were they working on this baby
when all of a sudden it pops up in the
spring and summer of 2020 right i want
to i want to ask you uh going back to
the fourth turning because we're talking
about the potential conflict now we're
getting into the china war stuff
there's a recent report that the the
pentagon has begun buying bombs
for weapons for use in pacific warfare
as opposed to middle east
middle eastern warfare we saw a report
that the u.s air force started spreading
out
its uh its resources to various islands
throughout the pacific because they were
concerned about single points of failure
and this was reported as being in
preparation for
a strike from china then we get china
sending 28 warplanes the most they've
ever done into taiwanese defensive
airspace
then we get as an aside sort of uh the
russian war games west of hawaii
and i'm wondering if in your face by the
way right right right
in your face but here's here's what
here's what i'm thinking
the us making these moves we're watching
that happen
certainly other things have happened in
this conflict that we wouldn't know
about before got to this point right
i guess i'm wondering if these physical
and overt signs we're seeing from the
chinese strike groups in the taiwan
strait these warplanes to the u.s making
these moves
are signs that it's become so obvious
war is coming
they're making moves in our face so i
said back on breitbart radio in 15 when
they had the problem with
japan and remember they cut the rare
earths off no yeah yeah they cut
so japan they had a problem with the in
the east china sea with with fishing
trawlers and then
fishing i think it was and the chinese
cut japan off of rare earth which means
no semiconductor business no electronics
business
and i said the time the japanese worked
it out okay kind of kowtowed and they
worked it out
and i said about these islands are
coming up these artificial islands
that within five to eight years if we
don't stop these guys now with
information economic warfare we're going
to be in a shooting war in the south
china i patrolled the south china sea as
a young naval officer the south china
sea is the most important
body of water in the world it connects
the persian gulf
straits of malacca with all the markets
throughout asia it's central to the
american economy and quite frankly
silicon valley west whether you have a a
you think you have a moral obligation to
defend the free chinese in taiwan
you've even if you don't think you have
a moral obligation to defend the
judeo-christian west
you have a hard economic interest that
silicon valley west
all of our advanced chip designers right
there we have to defend taiwan and we're
being
our backs being put up by the feckless
nature
of our elites let me just tell you this
whole concept of the thucydides trap
okay this is a concept that the elites
believe henry kissinger who's juan
xishan's best friend
right the real hatchet man in china that
throughout history like spar
sparta and athens you've had 15 times
you had a declining power and a rising
power
and you know 12 of the 15 times have
been a global conflict
but if the elites of the declining power
are smart you can kind of nudge the
rising power in there and you get them
to
to to to to live i heard that it was um
jake sullivan said after we wanted 16
one of the things he was telling people
i think fareed zakar told me this that
he had said hey the one thing that
bannon got right in this thing
is that uh we're not the declining power
right
we're in decline by our managed lease
but we have all the cards right now we
have the capital markets we have access
to
the dollar we have access to our
technology you know she when
when trump negotiated the big deal the
lighthouse deal in 19 the spring of 19
that huge deal with the seven verticals
that that
that navarre talk about and she and juan
xishan
reviewed that deal in in april and may
and came back and said deal off not
doing it
well the deal was basically it would
restructure chinese economy to bring it
into the to the world it would
stop their state-owned industries and
really destroy the slave labor and make
the whole
this deal was the best deal we would
ever get with the chinese to integrate
him into the world economy
the lighthouse and nevada negotiated it
the chinese reviewed it lee hub was the
guy they went back and looked at it and
they said
you know upon further review this is a
port treaty if we do this we will always
be subservient to the west and we're not
going to do it
he told people internally we are 20
years still behind the west we have to
steal most of the stuff
so we have to expedite this we have to
get on a five-year program
because we're at war with these guys and
we're either going to count down to them
or we're going to be able to stand up
and we're going to be able to dictate
the terms and that's in the spring of 19
is when this is remember so many smart
people
have said this is that geopolitically
the most important thing they actually
talked about
technologically decoupling from america
that their own they would build their
they would have their own amazons and
their own googles and they were technic
they would not be
uh they would not be for our chip design
and all the advanced
engineering that we do that they still
need they said we're going to get all
off of this because we still count out
to the west so does that
spring of 19 is one of the biggest
inflection points
in this conflict right and everything
biden's doing today is all just this
just all happy talks you saw the meeting
with uh blinken
where china said you're not in a
position of strength you know you are
not coming to us from from a position of
strength so i guess
just to reiterate um you mentioned we
may
come to the point where there's kinetic
war let's talk about the blinking
meeting because they're all about face
and formality
tony blanken had you know by the way
he's totally compromised he was part of
the university of pennsylvania and
harvard and these things jake sullivan
taking money
left and right from the chinese
communist party to fund these ivy league
universities it's a disgrace and i say
that somebody's a harvard graduate
it's a disgrace you're taking blood
money from lao beijing from the
money doesn't come for free it comes off
the sweat of the china the decent some
of the most decent people on this earth
that's where the money comes from the
criminal class on wall street that's in
business
with them and the universities to take
that money blinking reads his little
two-minute
formal thing to that dude tyga yang sits
there for 20 minutes and lectures him
you're not telling us what to do you
have no moral authority what to do
and the reason they're able to lecture
is they don't fear our elites
they don't fear our elites and that i'm
telling you symbolically throughout the
world everybody took notice of that
because the by administration what he
should have done is said hey thank you
very much you should have called by and
by
and said get the plane on and come home
no more meeting no more talk
this is the humiliation of the west they
know our elites are
feckless they know they're weak and more
importantly
they know that they're bought in we're a
tributary state right now
we ship the trade deficit this year is
going to be a trillion dollars
we're financing their military we're
financing their attack on us
well here's what happens we ship over
raw materials and beef and soybeans and
timber
and coal and and and oil and all that
and they ship back advanced
manufacturing products that should be
here in the united states of america and
guess what
they may cost a little bit is that the
end of the world is the end of the world
that this thing's going to cost a little
bit more is the end of the world of the
product if you've got good paying jobs
and families with good paying jobs
right and the wife if she doesn't want
to doesn't have to work but can sit home
and raise three four or five kids
okay is that is there some law of
physics that says
that it's it's terrible to have to pay
more for products no
it is not if wages rise this is the
central dilemma
our elites are compromised they're weak
and our enemy the biggest existential
threat we've ever had in the nation's
history
understands that they're weak and
feckless and understands they've been
bought and compromised
you so you've mentioned their compromise
is it possible then that
they're just fumbling on purpose so that
we avoid thucydides trap and china just
kind of wedges their way
in and we falter i think it's i think
it's not fumbling on purpose i think
it's part of the they don't want to
confront anybody look at kendrick henry
chris is now warning us about a cold war
we're not in a cold war
war is three parts as they tell us in
unrestricted warfare
you have an information part cyber and
an economic partner kinetic
they're at hot war with us on
information warfare and cyber
they're at a hot war with us on
economics okay that is a hot not a cold
war that's a hot war
thank god we haven't slipped to the
inexorably slipped to the kinetic war
you know why his who's going to pay for
it the kids are the people in my
destroyer were all
working class people that's is going to
pay for it the same
people that are buried in every patriot
grave in every battlefield throughout
the world
okay in world war one in world war ii
and vietnam and korea the same
working-class people who who thanklessly
and it was thankless okay had to go over
there and take care of all these messes
europe got in
all these messes that communism drove
right
think think of the the quality of
individual that
served and dedicated and went and fought
for this country with no thanks and
don't tell me
oh the veterans thank you for your
service they're they're gone their
futures are gone their children are gone
they were destroyed crushed
right that's the kinetic war worship and
every veteran knows that
they understand what's those bombers
coming over then when russia sends
a fleet off off of the west coast off of
pearl harbor
is doing exercises in what's called the
hawaiian op area and that's where the
u.s navy transitions
the third fleet goes to the seventh
fleet you work up the russians are right
there because they're in your face you
know why
they understand our elites are weak and
they will not
push back you wanna you wanna know
something interesting i heard and uh
maybe it's not true but uh i think it's
true
that it exemplifies what you're saying
about the working class being the ones
who go off and die
you know why smith is the most common
last name
or at least in the west so smith
schmidt etc when wars broke out the
smiths wouldn't go to war
they would stay and make weapons and
when a country was captured the smiths
wouldn't be executed they would
use their knowledge of making weapons to
empower their conquerors so naturally
those last name smith were more likely
to survive
the people who don't go to war
surprisingly the ones who make the
weapons
are the ones who continue to live on and
expand and i mean no disrespect to
anybody named smith
i'm just pointing out that a lot of
people are
used for cannon fodder by the wealthy
elites and the military-industrial
complex
who are the modern blacksmiths if you
want to see anything more than this look
at the disaster in the 20s
we're supposed to be a great power
here's what a great power we are
our elites sent us to these middle
eastern wars that were wars of choice
you could have cut as trump showed with
isis you go in there
that that state that had had come up
between syria and iraq
was more vibrant more robust he sent you
know with mattis they and we got the the
the local guys also do the fighting the
the the the militias
but we destroyed isis the physical
caliphate in what a year year and a half
these wars of choice have cost us
according to brown university what nine
tr the net present value is
nine trillion dollars now please imagine
what this nation would be like
if you're taking that nine trillion
dollars and you put it into saint louis
you put it into detroit you put
with advanced manufacturing jobs what
this would be
paradise on earth yeah we have ten
thousand dead
all almost to a person working class and
middle class people
we have another what thirty or 40 000
horrible injuries
and how many ptsd there's 40 veterans a
day killing themselves
killing themselves these casualties of
war is because a neocon
neoliberal elite whose children do not
fight these wars
send everybody else out to fight them
how many years
did we hear about the pipes in flint
that didn't get fixed
my understanding is at the end of last
year they actually repaired them things
are better
and i i just said this i was like hey
here's here's a compromise we end the
war stop spending money over there and
just fix the pipes in flint everyone's
happy right
why can't that stuff get done because
they they they want to be
a global cop everywhere with president
trump one of the things before i left
the white house is fighting over
afghanistan
and look i i'm a proud veteran i'm a
patriot
i love the military but i don't love the
military to be
used to destroy it and you're in
afghanistan now for 20 years you've
added up the combat history of the
revolution
the civil war world war one world war ii
we're there in one place
longer than the combat history of
everything it's a forever war
and they i saw the way it worked they
lied to president trump i sit there
show us the number oh it's gonna be 10
billion no it's 42 or 52 billion dollars
i go around give speeches would you if
you're in st louis would you rather have
give them 10 billion do whatever they
want and let them steal it all
but take the other 32 billion and let's
put it back in st louis for
everybody vote for that unanimous but
first off of the 9
trillion dollars let's go to afghanistan
i want to see the roads i want to see
the schools for the little girls and we
see the hospitals because it must be
nirvana
everybody should want to move to
afghanistan we asked them show me that
you support
i got the taxpayer paid the two the nine
trillion dollars
right and part of its net present value
but the cash money three four five
trillion dollars trillion
just show me the photographs where are
they
you can't do it they can't do it they
can't the place is still as president
trump would say
a [ __ ] right yeah yes sorry about
that for your thing but no
because and hey because they've stolen
and they've grown the poppies are bigger
than ever
this is what is not a great power runs
itself and yet
what are they doing you got to stay in
the lindsey graham you got to stay in
there you got to do this you got to
no you don't you got to come home and
then you got to tell them
if any type of terrorism or terrorism
networks were going to come in
and destroy it no questions asked okay
we're going to start
acting like adults and stop acting like
children and that's what these
neoliberal neocons draft off of
i heard that one of the first things
donald trump did when he got in was he
said i want
i want afghanistan over within like the
first few months is that true the first
two days first two days i want to plan
to get out of afghanistan and i'm going
to get a free answer and by the way and
so did it happen the poppies
the heroine
they had the last meeting because they
sat there with president trump said no
the taliban they're going to do this
they're going to do that they're going
to come back
you just look at everything and also you
go back and say hey
let me see the presentations that were
made to the commander in chiefs
because we've been here through all of
bush and obama right
i want to see the presentations that
were made at the critical inflection
points it's always the same presentation
in 18 months it's better right it's
always an 18 month you know it's the
projection they're going up like every
18 months we're out
it's all first off it's gross
incompetence
number two it's also corruption and
number three it's also the mindset of
the elites there's no will to win
because they want to be there they want
to be in 140 countries
they want to be everywhere power
corrupts
and absolute power crops we were never
set up to be an empire
the great thing of our revolutionary
generation and that's what i love about
the millennials on the left and the
right
the populace on the left and the right
they have a revolutionary spirit that
things have to change
that's what drove the revolutionary
generation to go against the
aristocracies of the world and the
divine right of kings
that people can actually govern
themselves the consent of the
government's everything and this is what
afghanistan showed no
the elites want us to be there and we're
going to be there was trump
able to stamp the paper and say we're
done we're out
did what was it at the end was it
ultimately not not in that 17 they
they misrepresented and lied to him and
said we got to be in it but that's
compromise this is what i'm asking did
trump say oh okay i guess we have to
stay
i i wasn't there for the final meeting
but the meetings leading up to that when
they kind of put me back on the national
security council and say let's come up
with three alternatives the alternatives
is that
withdraw immediately ad troops which the
staying was actually adding people
okay in the middle was let's get a
paramilitary
cia bad hombres special forces
that stay in for some reduce get big
army out of there some reduced thing to
kill
bad guys and to make sure they can't do
terrorist things and that middle ground
was not selected it was selected to be
that with a plan to come back and
withdraw president trump at the end of
it in a couple of years finally said
i've had enough of this
we're coming home and i think it's the
reason that i do him and they blocked
him
they listen the apparatus and this is
why and look i'm a huge believer in the
military
there's something seriously wrong with
the national security
state there's something wrong with the
fbi there's something wrong with the cia
the national security apparatus
is all powerful we need a church
commission we need to immediately
have people in the in congress with
others sit there and review
the fbi the cia and dod
we got to get to the bottom of what our
purpose is what we're trying to do
what's acceptable to do against american
citizens in the united states
right what it's acceptable to do
overseas and what our whole purpose is
right now particularly when we have an
existential threat in the chinese
communist party it's not like hey
we get a free pass and we can kind of
rethink this remember if you think about
it for a second just look at the world
geopolitically
western europe just go around the world
island western europe
the persian gulf the south china sea and
then up to if you think about a map
up to northwest around japan and korea
okay there's four hot spots around the
world island that which
traditionally in the post-war uh world
war ii world is where we kind of
structure this
if you look at those sections it's a
combination in every area
of capital markets commercial
relationships
trade deals right and an american
security guarantee
nato does it come on the nato's israel
it's built as a security
for the suez canal basically the state
of israel is our partner but that whole
area
and trying to get uae and and and saudi
arabia against
obviously iran which is partners with
china but my point is
it's capital markets trade deals
commercial relationships
and an american security guarantee in
all four of them trump's
thing was hey it's time for locally you
got to step up to the plate
the u.s taxpayer and particularly the
deplorable remember it's their kids
down on the border in ukraine it's their
kids in the hindu kush
on patrol it's their kids on patrol in
the south china sea and it's their kids
up on the 28th or 38th parallel in korea
it's the working-class people in this
country's
taxes and it's their children that are
doing this and that's why
i think people said hey we've got to do
a big rethink here
why is nato getting a free pass i'm a
big believer in nato but you got to pull
your weight why the germans pay under
one percent
of of they pay our supplemental bill
that trump put forward in 17 we first
got there to take care of maintenance
was bigger than the entire german uh
defense budget
germany's economy is what four or five
trillion dollars it was one-third
of what ours was and and our thing was
780 billion to a trillion dollars theirs
is 35 or 40 trillion
billion the global banks bank of
international settlements have basically
co-opted the united states government
it's like a parasite causing us to print
with this fiat unlimited money to fund
an unlimited war
they're using this this american system
i wouldn't but i wouldn't say it's the
bis i think it's the capital markets i
think it's wall street the city of
london and
and you're absolutely correct their
their objectives now is and that's why
it's doing
it's just to continue to print money
continue to print money that's what's
leading to the destruction of the us
dollar
that's why people got to start looking
at alternative investments you gotta
and and i'm not a prepper but you would
be a
fool you would let yourself down you
would not do the fiduciary
responsibility
to yourself or your family if you don't
start looking at alternatives that could
happen
right you saw this with the collapse of
the the energy situation in texas
the fuel situation you have you have to
right now to protect yourself and your
family you have to say
hey i'm not a prepper because the
preppers get a little scary for me right
but i got as a logical person i got to
think about food i got to think about
energy i got to think about
gold i got to think about crypto i got
to think about every other possibility
including what i normally do in my
normal life i'll tell you something
we have a we have a sponsor we do the uh
uh
my patreon supply safeandreadymeals.com
we promote them every so often
and these are these food bins they last
for 25 years you crack them open and uh
this is not a problem i'm just
explaining what it is because
this is relevant we had a storm come
through here a couple weeks ago
all the power was out for i think like
eight hours
we did the show why i have backup
batteries we have small portable backup
batteries
that we immediately brought up stairs we
had like i think we have like eight of
them or more
and we plugged them all in and
everything ran just fine it was really
hot because you can't really do air
conditioning with it but we managed to
do the show
and like we had some light but we made
it work why
sometimes it rains and when it happens
sometimes the power line goes down
so having backup batteries is not
prepping necessary i guess you are
prepping
but when we when i promo these food bins
periodically maybe like once
a month or a couple times every other
month the leftists many of these like
left establishment pro like i shouldn't
say leftists i i always try to
differentiate between economic leftists
and like establishment
individuals they just make a game ha ha
tim's so dumb he's selling these bins
and i'm like let me ask you something
it's like you have a first aid kit in
your house do you know where it
is a lot of people will say i do have it
i don't know where it is why because you
never really use it
but you have it you eat food every day
this is what's crazy to me that we're in
this period where you have
people shaming others for preparing for
what could be a major crisis especially
when we're talking about the fourth
turning
or through cities trap i'm like am i
gonna fill up an underground bunker with
like you know a hundred years worth of
food
no but i'll get a bunch of you know
30-year food bins we got a lot of
employees here
and then we'll have food why your worst
case scenario is you eat it
it's it's it lasts forever so you have
food but there are people who genuinely
shame others
for the idea that something bad might
happen like i don't know a tornado
tornado just hit chicago
you see that i had people hit me up no
joke a tornado actually landed in
chicago suburbs
all my life it's always been warnings
never actually i saw a photo of it i was
i was surprised
and people are trapped in their homes
and they have no food these things
happen but there are people that are
indoctrinated by the media by this
narrative that preppers are all insane
so you should not be prepared for a
disaster that's what i was saying the
the financial literacy we just picked up
my uh my patreon supply
about a month ago we do it once a week
or something but the reason they
attracted it to me
if you just look at the logic why would
you not have a 30-day food supply
given things that happened in texas
given the things that happened on the
east coast with the gasoline
today that's what i'm saying just step
back for a second because they do make
the preppers out to be
to be you know to be crazy but just step
back and and just look at the facts
why would you not have a backup
generator why would you not have a
30-day food supply
why did you not do the logical things
that would put you in a position
that you wouldn't have to sit there and
wait for government to come and help you
god bless the guys of fema they do
men and women feeling do a fantastic job
but you can't sit there and go
i'm waiting on fema you've got to be in
this day and age at least
to have some modicum of support you know
what i find fascinating we mentioned
this the other day in the bonus segment
tbs.com
the people in the cities tend to be more
liberal they tend to be the ones
very very concerned about climate change
they also tend to be the ones that are
the least self-sufficient
and self-self-sustaining and the least
likely to actually uh recycle and
compost
and you look at conservatives living
more likely live in rural areas
much less likely be concerned about
climate change much more likely to have
their own farms their own gardens their
own goats their own chickens
to compost and consume less and have
their own backup generators
and produce wind or solar it's
fascinating isn't it
it is that's what i think the real thing
of being a conservative is
is to conserve right to know how to live
to know how to live
i think the media is the problem the
media whips everybody into a frenzy
everybody fights i think we're guilty of
it to a certain degree and it's
it's not the media node the media is
it's different though and i think
marshall mcluhan marshall mcloone said
this is why i keep saying
trump is the first mclean s president
maybe obama
is that what mcluhan said back in the in
the 50s
right it was at washington university in
st louis he was a theoretician he said
hey
this was just with radio and movies and
tv was just starting
he said this thing of mass
communications is so
powerful it's going to overtake
evolutionary
you know biology it's going to start to
be the thing that drives
the evolution of man that is going to so
and co
incorporates so much right and that's
what you have today you live
in a world of not just media it it
permeates everything that's what i said
at the time
the opposition parties not the democrats
the opposition parties the media
they're more powerful they're more in
every aspect of it
they and just look what's happened over
the last couple years particularly with
things like the ccp virus the virus from
wuhan
things like uh you know other aspects i
think and i'm a big elections guy but
things happen there
that you have these narratives and you
can't go across you know miles gross
said told me a couple of years ago he
says
nuclear weapons are not the most
powerful weapons in the world monica
what do you mean
he says the social media i go miles what
are you talking about he said
if if dc was hit with a nuclear weapon
trump whoever is president go in the
bunker hit back with other nuclear
weapons
they can disappear you they can
disappear you
by shutting you off ulcers right this
was years before trump has been i said
you're crazy
he goes it's more powerful because media
permeates everything
nuclear weapons is just a weapon this is
fascinating uh when we had ben stewart
on the show talking about the fourth
turning he mentioned
that the theory suggests the most
powerful weapons of the time will be
used in
the great in the crisis and the concern
was nuclear weapons and my immediate
thought was it's social media social
media
you you have you ever played the game
civilization
sid meier civilization ian i know i love
it yeah amazing game
you basically you start from nomadic
little tribesmen settlers and you build
civilization you develop technology
and then the game comes to an end when
you have massive countries borders are
pressing upon borders it's a brilliant
game i think kids should have to play in
school because it teaches you a lot
but one of the most interesting things
is how you can win a cultural victory
there's several ways to win you can take
everybody over with force you can
colonize other planets
or there's a cultural victory where your
influence spreads so far and wide people
just start
joining your country you can in in the
game you can actually take over cities
and their borders by producing so much
culture
that the people now feel more
represented by you and your way of life
than their own country
imagine what happens when the nba and
blizzard these video games
are all now defending the ccp mocking
hong kong
not letting you buy free hong kong gear
that's what we're experiencing
for those that understand video games
china is going for the cultural victory
here
and it's working out fairly well for
them for the time being 100 percent not
even a question that's what we've got
this is why this fight is right now
and it's a fight that's information
which is part of the cultural
right in economic and it's a hot war
it's a hot war not not a cold war
i'll uh before we go into superheat i'll
say one more thing if that's hot war
then we're in a hot civil war
trump supporters being banned and purged
some of the highest profile supporters
of
the of the man have been completely
removed working-class individuals who
say learn to code to mock the idea they
should give up their jobs and go work in
a different industry are all purged
that is the information warfare the
things we can't say on this show will
get banned but hey
i i can do a debate with jack dorsey and
vijayagada on the joe rogan podcast
where i can show them an example of
antifa advocating for extreme violence
and they won't remove it but a trump
supporter can make a joke and
they're gone so that is information
warfare but that's economic
they've started banning conservatives
there's bank accounts oh yeah
deep platforming d financing d all of
that kind of
critical physical violence and people
killed so it may be the cusp
of kinetic warfare i hope it doesn't
proceed further here's the thing
is that we can color inside the lines
and win this there's a realignment
and i think we're going to be able to
prove at the end of the day that
this vote count on november 3rd and to
me that's one of the only things that
matter all this other nonsense about
you know more voting laws and all this
different stuff is a misdirection play
in a way for the republicans the rnc to
raise money you got to get to the bottom
just like in wuhan lab you got to get to
the bottom of november 3rd and you got
to get there with
facts facts hard fact evidence and facts
and i think you're going to see what i
say
there's already been a realignment i'm
not going to say the magic word because
i don't
say that for africa no but my point is
is that
this there's been a realignment in this
country look at look at
look at the rio grande valley the smart
i think it's henry gonzalez a smart old
democrat in in south texas he's sitting
there going waving the flag saying guys
if you don't get down here with real
policies the republicans are going to
start sweeping
hispanic southern texas south texas
that's going to happen
you're seeing a realignment was it 14 or
15 percent forget the number of
african-american males voted for trump
you're seeing
a realignment it's before you and don't
buy all the stuff you see on msnbc and
all that there's a realignment of
working class people and middle class
people
to their economic interest right their
economic interests to say hey look
i like these policies i don't like the
globalists i don't like the open borders
bernie's right it is a koch brothers
program with these open borders
right although bernie for political
expediency
right expediency said the opposite it's
one of the reasons he's not
president of the united states when he
very much could have been president
either 16
or in 20. so i think there's been a
realignment it's going to be even bigger
and i'm telling you
this coalition of working-class and
middle-class people
based around populism and economic
nationalism is going to govern this
country
for a hundred years and we're going to
have the fight is not between each other
the fight is between a corrupt and
distant
elite woke globalist elite in the
working class of middle class people in
this country
you can't go at china and defeat them
like that it's like two
two rocket ships each traveling and our
goal is which can be the better rocket
ship you don't want to ram into them and
destroy
you want to get there faster better we
need a new industry you guys talked
about industry a few times on this
and have you heard of graphene yeah okay
graphene is the 21st century steel yes
if the united states retrofits their
economy you build graph yes fast quick
cheap sell it across the world yes i
think what we can do let me know what
you think about this
set up a 15-year plan where we build
like a university where we
taxpayer funded to go learn how to make
graphene
after 15 years we make it a utility and
all the graphene that's produced there
is then free for the citizens to utilize
so like the roads
lower the taxes on the roads you put it
in car bodies the cars are cheaper now
actually this is this is fascinating so
carbonizing batteries yes
with graphene so they can charge faster
but this would let's take what the ccp
did
they announced 10 years ago called made
in china 2025
right and they were going to dominate 10
industries right
in the industries they said advanced
chip design artificial intelligence
robotics biotechnology they just go down
and say and by the way
all of those combined lead to the fourth
industrial revolution and they made a
national commitment to do it
we can do that people say you can't yes
we can make a national commitment to be
have national champions and dominate
those industries and have our allies
we haven't had the political will
because
wall street and the global corporations
own our political class
okay our political class and our
political class caltos
they'd rather have china have it because
then they got all the slave labor of the
poor chinese to support that
okay and this is the problem those
things in graphene all that would be
part of it right
we should be the leaders in all of that
we're the leaders in r d
in in applied research but we let it be
made everywhere else and the great thing
a wall street says oh
if you do the r d and you do all that
you're going to create well you create
the value to a very small band
of folks not to the not to the to the
great bulk of society
we have to return all that we have to
take they're made in china 2025
say hey how about this made in america
2025 oligarchs they run the copper
industry basically they don't want to
lose the
monopoly on the wire industry the wires
copper wires is like a huge
and the coal and oil they don't want to
lose it to graphene
so it's it's a it should be mainstream
media
this is the thing this is pure carbon i
mean this
this is it in hydrogen i mean also the
hydrogen i agree with you by the way i
agree with you that but to me
that's almost got to be a driving force
you've got to you've got to get people
aware of that you got to start pushing
it you got to start talking about it
every day
i mean you're clearly very very
enthusiastic about it that enthusiasm's
got to get out there
and get into the capital markets right
now it's looked at let's do the advanced
r d
and we'll let china go make it right and
will china have that high value added
jobs
not paying the chinese for it we're
still going to use them as slave labor
and that's the way we keep keep wages
down throughout the world and that's not
conspiracy
dems just happens to be the way the
system works
let's jump over to the super chats to
see what the the audience and the
questions for many of these individuals
here
and then uh as for the more spicier
conversations go to timcast.com become a
member
because after we wrap up here about a
half an hour so we're going to carry on
the conversation which should be
published around 11 p.m
and then we're going to ask a bunch of
the questions that you know youtube
would ban us for because
that's the way the uh the information
warfare works
so you can check it out at timcast.com
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show and let's read
all right let's see um
all right what do we got brian fontenot
says you don't read seeking alpha for
the articles you'll read it for the
comments
long amd all right
dr rollergater says if i were a chief
strategist and i spent two months in the
nsc i would look up all sorts of
intelligence that might be useful for
parallel construction when i leave the
white house
but maybe that's just me how about you
parallel construction
yeah i'm not familiar it's like building
things there uh so you know about all
the aliens i guess but you just can't
tell us
i think the question about the aliens is
why is this information coming out right
now yes
we're gonna have one of the look this is
a very serious topic
this is a very serious topic um we're
going to have one the congressman the
republican congressman's on the show
for a whole hour on thursday because i
want to go through this this is a very
serious topic
but i think that hey we got a dumpster
fire right now in the country
why is the timing particularly since i
don't think
that much has been added in knowledge
since i was there in 17 right
i'm interested to see that but the
question is why now
like i said this is a serious topic
and people have to address it as a
serious topic one of the things
let me just step back for a second
besides ufos let's go back to that
chinese
made in china 2025. the bigger threat
and the real reason i'm a populist i
said this at a
speech years ago and a couple years ago
in italy
the convergence of these technologies
the convergence of advanced chip design
artificial intelligence or artificial
general intelligence robotics or
regenerative robotics
and bio and basically biotechnology or
gene splicing
the convergence of those technologies is
going to lead to what's called the
singularity
and then that's going to lead to what is
transhumanism it's going to be post-homo
sapien
now that fact
that fact is going to happen in the
lived experience of people listening and
watching the show today
okay won't be me but it'll be others
that is going to be
the central inflection point in mankind
right that we know is coming because we
can see where these things
and that is completely unregulated
totally not talked about
your tax styles are paying for a lot of
the stuff in darpa of this research
that's going on
and nobody the elites in the world do
not want this
discussed whatsoever it's one of the
reasons in this new
theology of scientism they do not want
the barbarians getting to the
to the temple that is the wuhan
laboratory they don't want any of the
barbarians to ever question
what the high priests say about the
temple that are these research labs and
to me
this is one of the new and it's going to
come it's going to be forced
by a populist movement in this country
this summer
when the mothers of america many of whom
hate the name donald trump
many of whom voted against donald trump
many of whom are progressives and they
and their husbands got vaccinated
when they get back to school in base in
mid-august and
according to fauci to get to herd
immunity we have to vaccinate the school
children
okay not just the adolescents but the
kids from babies to
10 or 11 when those vaccines are going
to be put forward
and people know if your kids aren't
vaccinated they're going to be put over
here in this corner
this is going to be a firestorm and that
ties back to this whole
system of this scientific kind of priest
cast that kind of does this without
anybody questioning it and i gotta tell
you
this situation of transhumanism if we
allow as people of the world and
particularly people the united states
to allow what's happening there the same
way globalization just kind of came
about
and all sudden it was a thing after 30
or 40 years of being told
and all of a sudden you had this system
that was in place and now you've got to
go out
and strike against it to dismantle it
because it's destroying working-class
people
if the same thing happens with the
conversion of these technologies and
we're just asleep
trust me the the the because right now
you see with artificial intelligence the
jobs and the jobs that get crushed are
working-class jobs
all right let's see uh king tesseract
says tim you just don't get it
quote don't subsidize those that hate
you that's the point of neoliberalism
the entire economy gives the left free
power
when the dems embraced olinskyism
society itself was poisoned forever
radicals brilliant but you got to read
it brilliant it's it's
it's brilliant that in the little red
book shows you how the
the frankfurt school the cultural
marxists are going to take over so
linsky's a hammer
we need we need a saw linskies on the
right yeah i mean
uh that's tim paul mm-hmm is it i don't
know but i want you to i want you to be
you're tough on bray by the way stacey
abrams and
if hey i admire him i want a stacey
abrams on the right
i want people that are fighters and she
will not back down
the problem we have on the right is to
me these feckless pencil neck
politicians will not stand up and fight
they don't be called racist they don't
want to be they want to be in the club
they want to go to the country
club they want to go in the nice
restaurants yeah hey in this day and age
you can't do that you got to be able to
fight they care more about what the new
york times thinks of them than their own
constituents amen i saw that on twitter
but uh we got to try and read let's go
bobby bob says what do you think the
reaction to a trump 2024 win will be
uh it'll be tough but what about a tr i
can't say that we'll have to wait to
what about it was there a loss in 2020
or you said no
um trump's first off we're going to take
the midterms in 2022 with uh we won 62
seats in 2010
with the tea party revolt this is the
tea party to the 10th power
we're going to win 40 to 50 seats in
2022 and trump is going to have a
sweeping victory in 2024 and the left
is just going to have to deal with it is
going to be trump desantis
i have no earthly idea it will be but
it'll be trump i have no
idea who who the vp will be i think
it'll be trump i'm kind of feeling
he's got a lot of uh dave's you know
dave smith libertarian party yeah sure
what do you think about dave i'm not a
libertarian ah
i'm not a libertarian everybody i'm an
anti-libertarian can we actually
because the libertarians kochs are
libertarians they believe in open
borders and they believe in free flow of
capital you don't believe in either big
libertarian like the libertarian party i
mean the concept of the libertarian you
tell me what else it is besides
on the political spectrum libertarian
meaning less like there's
authoritarianism and libertarianism
libertarianism focus on the individual
and freedom
things like that whereas
authoritarianism is the hierarchies
control the system etcetera
okay i like that part of the little l
but the problem is it gets translated
into
open borders and and and free flow of
capital i'm not the one
there there's there's an interesting
debate between libertarians like big
libertarian as to whether they're open
borders or closed borders there are a
lot of libertarians that say
borders are imaginary lines you're crazy
but there are a lot of libertarians that
say how can you even maintain your
freedoms without defending
where your freedoms are i've got to meet
those libertarians
are they okay well then those are good
guys this is one of the problems with
the libertarian party
is that you have a guy get up on stage
to take his pants off because he thinks
libertarian means he can do whatever he
wants
never teen right right right right i was
studying the spanish-american war
1898 the spanish empire basically
controlled cuba and the americans
decided to liberate cuba and they're
like we're not going to take cuba we're
just going to liberate it so they did
and then a dictator took over so like is
there a point where
liberating a country and just letting it
go is detrimental
like you're saying government oversight
is important you want
big libertarians to laise fair you know
corporations will take over
but at some point do you use the
militant arm of force to
keep people free i hate imperialism but
letting cast
letting that country go independent and
castro sees his command is like i don't
i hate that too
so is this ever balanced yeah yeah i
don't know if you want to address that
it has to be a balance i mean you gotta
to me you've got i don't know about
going in and
liberating people people have to want to
liberate themselves one of the things
we've seen in afghanistan
they don't really want democracy as we
define it
you've had these globalists in there for
20 years always want to do the elections
and
it's not working right we're trying to
force on them
our system people have to want to want
that system
right they and have to fight for it
everybody's got to fight eventually for
their freedom
right i think and if we're there to
assist in certain situations
then we're there to assist but i think
we got to be very remember the founders
said
don't go throughout the world looking
for dragons to slay
there's enough dragons here here's the
tough question in the civil war
abraham lincoln did a lot of
questionably authoritarian things right
suspension he was a warlord
right questionable he was a warlord sure
sure a suspension of a baby
that's what it took to destroy look
sherman told him you're going to have to
burn the south to the ground and he did
to win
he tried it for no they tried at first
to do the army you know to do the arm
be the army and stuff like that and
eventually he understood sherman who
they thought was crazy at the beginning
was right you're going to have to you're
going to defeat
the plantation aristocracy in the south
giving the fighting spirit of the south
and they had their dander up
you're going to have to go in and burn
the south to the ground columbia south
carolina
charleston south carolina richmond
virginia atlanta georgia
right to the sea the marshall we talked
about it recently in 18
look remember people forget this lincoln
did not
run as a republican in 1864.
he ran as on the national union party he
had to reach out to a democrat which was
andrew
johnson who was at east tennessee
remember east tennessee the scottish
highlanders up there
had did not truck with the plantation
aristocracy they wanted to break off
so he ran as a joint thing up until the
fall of atlanta
in on september 1st 1864
lincoln was losing to mcclellan who had
been his you know this thing and he
thought this thing was over actually
signed a thing to his cabinet says
if i'm when i'm defeated i don't know if
i'm turning power over in march because
i'm going to finish we're going to
finish
this rebellion on my watch so you had
that
then you also had things in like world
war ii like the u.s office of censorship
right a lot of suspension of civil
liberties when it comes to
to warfare so when dealing with the
internal conflict we face
or the potential war with china is it
just reality that
people are going to be faced with
sacrificing civil liberties
when war breaks out well war has already
broken out and i think you're already
facing civil liberty charges look at it
up until the last two weeks if you
mentioned wuhan lab
or the ccp or that it came or something
like that
you're banned from we're close to it
anyway well the reason we got banned for
twitter i don't i've never had a twitter
account there's dozens of fake accounts
i've never had a twitter account
war room pandemic had a twitter account
you know we put it out jack just don't
say what got your bands well no no
wait what he was putting up well what
got banned was what they said i said
about fouchy and ray which was a
metaphor
right about thomas more as i said no but
what we really got banned for was
putting up
the raw footage of the hard drive from
hell
which we said hey you come for the porn
and you stay for the compromise
right you come from all and we were
putting up to some pretty
but that's that's where they got that's
what they really wanted to come down
that's
that's us losing our liberties in that
war 100
i think we have lost i think by the way
the chinese communist party is pretty
good about putting cultural power
in the newspapers the new york times or
the washington post that all have the
china daily china daily is pravda
that's propped inside their their thing
uh yesterday
when fauci does kara swisher's her top
podcast and if you're in the tech
business you go to her podcast she's a
mover and shaker
she's got that great podcast in the
middle of podcast sponsored by huawei
right huawei is the i purged that they
purged that
i saw people tweeting saying that they
they came in later and removed the are
you kidding me i didn't even see that
well i saw
i saw people tweeting about it fact
check me guys who are listening right
but she's
screaming is the i.t department of the
pla
okay it's the people's liberation army's
telecommunication division let's be
brutally frank about that
okay and and and she's sponsored and
found she's sitting there
still trying to do the misdirection play
hey just saying we'll read some more of
these we got uh
keyblade uh keyblade master andy says
tim makes a solid pitch for crypto
but as far as investing many people like
myself don't even know where to begin
uh coinbase yeah that's a good one
coinbase uh website they're definitely
overloaded but it's functional
yeah gemini uh very very easy to use
services they want to make it easy for
regular people
all right let's see we got ooh some
people have retracted messages
oh all right uh gg player says question
for steve
telling business what to do with their
capital and their facilities sounds like
it might need a right authorian
right authoritarian approach it's
interesting
uh we try not to be authorita
authoritarian but
at some point in time i don't believe in
the free total free flow of capital
outside the united states
right because otherwise you say oh
you're going to increase taxes on the
wealth you're just going to take all
their money out
of the united states if you do with
these corporations well hey hang on if
you're domi's out here
and you uh you live with the blessings
of liberty
that are provided by working-class and
middle-class people
that provide the substrate of civic
society and support provide the security
not just the police officers and the
in the emts and the nurses but the
military
and these veterans and these active duty
people all over if you have the
blessings of liberty
you got to put a little something in the
pot okay and it shows you the scam
the 25 billion that's what that's what
you know and it's it's merrick garland i
think it's here in the
the the scam is u.s investigators this
is
the page of the financial times from the
other day u.s investigates leak of
records
showing billionaires pay tax hikes it's
not investigating the billionaires of
why they're not paying the taxes
the number one thing this is u.s that
was merrick garland
joe biden so all you guys have voted for
biden embrace this
don't give me your populism and how
you're going to do this you're going to
do that
this is what you voted for yeah and so
when the billionaires the 24
billionaires have paid
under 15 billion taxes over five years
okay the number one thing merrick
garland and joe biden wants to do
is find out who leaked the records
you're saying that's just taxes on the
books right
exactly that's tax on the books all
right so we don't have anything but but
so
yes is it i'm not a libertarian i don't
believe
in the total free flow of capital
throughout the world i think there has
to be some constraints on it and you
have to think of the national good and
the good
of the nation and i certainly don't
believe in the free flow of labor
because that only helps to impoverish
citizens
brian nola says first time hearing
bannon speak the media completely lied
he's incredibly intelligent and i
couldn't agree with him more
i'll be seeking his podcast out bravo
good sir thank you i think it's fairly
obvious like all the media about you was
just the most ridiculous lies
like far right authoritarian white
supremacist was like the most insane
thing
because i've i've i've uh i'm pretty far
right i'm a populist
what does that mean being far right well
i don't agree i don't agree with this
kind of middle ground where you're gonna
i think that
people somebody has to stand up for the
working-class people in this country but
see the thing is when you're talking
about left and right you have to figure
you have to figure out where your
definitions are are you talking about
the political compass are you talking
about the
there there were like four different
left and right spectrums 10 years ago
there was left in terms of hierarchy and
right in terms of anarchy it was like
very strange how people were defining
left and right so typically in the
political compass far right just means
free market that doesn't mean anything
other than that and then authoritarian
right uh means like
i guess ideological control with a
pseudo free market
it's very strange how people define what
left and right means these days when you
say you're very much in favor of
defending the working class
the left argues that's far left
except i don't see their policies doing
that's either but first of all the first
thing you say
are you open borders are you for are you
for open borders if you're open borders
you're destroying
all you're doing is putting the work the
most intense competition
against the people least able to defend
themselves and that's the working class
you're flooding the zone what you're
doing is flooding the zone with cheap
labor
right and and people can and you're
flooding the schools in the health care
system it all collapses
and you're not part of it because you're
an elite right you're going
remember you have more in common with
people in paris and people in shanghai
and people in london
than you do with people in the rio
grande valley that's the difference
look i come from a blue-collar
principally democratic
family that you know are very
pro-military and that was kind of one of
the big breaks was the vietnam war but
it's it's
we're working-class people and this is
why i have such a
uh bond with the chinese people i went
to china early on as a young naval
office and fell in love with the country
and the people in lao beijing
they are the most decent family oriented
people on earth and they have been
crushed one of the greatest
civilizations on our planet
they've never voted they've never voted
they've never had any freedom whatsoever
they're still
under an imperial power which now is a
transnational criminal organization so
if i have to dedicate my life to
fighting for those people and giving
those people a voice and working-class
people hey
that's that's to me it's a it's a it's a
great gig i couldn't i couldn't imagine
anything better
right on and bother i don't also don't
give i could give two dams
what the media says or whatever says
because here's what's whether i go to
oxford or whether people come to show
they always say hey
they lied about you i like what you have
to say and that's all i care
just listen to the content and see if
you agree or disagree and listen to it
over time
yep jonathan fell says hey tim is
youtube censoring your channels and its
growth
statistic websites uh i will say this
because other people have asked um
for one thing is true youtube has
notified me that they're gonna be
removing subscribers from my channels
and not to worry about it
i don't know what that means they say
don't worry it's routine you'll see it
drop in your subscriber amount
sure whatever uh it could be a few
things one
we've got a lot of people saying they're
no longer getting notifications even
though they've
they've liked the videos they subscribed
to the channel and they hit the
notification bell youtube still does not
notify them of the stream
yeah that could be their thumb on the
scale another big aspect of what's
happening is
last year everybody's locked in their
houses and it's an election year
this means that political shows were
massive us
we were riding a wave man
we had i think like 130 million total
views across all platforms in september
and into what
and and again in october is massive and
into this year
i reduced the amount of content i'm
producing that affects growth
less people are interested in hard
political content talking about policy
and things like that a lot of people
it's summer
the lockdowns are ending they want to go
out and party they're not going to be
late at night watching these shows
so it could just be that a lot of people
who were watching politics because it
was an election year
stopped and now views go down and that's
a normal thing
you know a lot of the channels that do
culture war stuff talking about movies
and comics
are still seeing you know moderate
growth
my channels tend to be much more
political than that so it's no surprise
i'll tell you this
2022 our views will be massive 2023
it'll go down a little bit but then the
presidential election will be kicking
into 2023 anyway
so it'll skyrocket this is the year
where we just came off a presidential
election
no one really cares about the midterms
yet it's a lull period so
i will say this i do think they put
their thumb on the scales
i think they keep us out of the
mainstream recommendation system
meaning the only i think they've
quarantined politics
on youtube so that if you go to youtube
right now in a private tab you're going
to see mr beast you're going to see a
bunch of mainstream pop culture
they want they want to they're building
that up and over time slowly this
political space is going to shrink and
shrink and shrink and get smaller and
they're only going to allow certain
channels to actually function and
operate
they're going to find more and more
excuses to ban people and then maybe in
five years
channels like this won't exist on
youtube anymore it'll be just a foofy
disney plus kind of service
in which case while it exists you need
to go to timcast.com
become a member because we're going to
make our own rivaling streaming platform
we're going to do another podcast about
unexplained paranormal mysteries because
we want to do more than just news we
want to build culture and inspire people
and we want to make sure we have the
ability to challenge the establishment
media through news
through uh making culture through tv
shows through sitcoms
we're talking about funding a sitcom
we're talking about short films minidocs
all of that stuff
and that's what happens when you become
a member at timcast.com you're not just
getting access to the stuff you're
helping us fight back by building
culture
that's my plan man so share the video as
well and let's read some more super
chats
all right let's see what we got
we got a lot of super chats and a lot of
them are will make youtube very angry so
i'm trying to be very careful
obviously homies yup
all right let's see warlock home says mr
banner and tim
i'm from china and i'm a permanent
resident i have my family here
what will happen to us if the war breaks
out will we be deported or sent to camps
will we be given a chance to choose a
side
in mainland china the only people that
can overthrow the chinese countries
party are the chinese people
i think you have the diaspora the
chinese people about 250 million
three quarters of which support you and
of course your
friends and allies in the west the
chinese communist party is going to fall
because their criminal organization and
people are finally identifying calling
out
uh sir we hope and i pray that civil war
does not break down china but it won't
if the chinese people put their shoulder
to the wheel but what about hot war
between the u.s and china what will that
mean i mean
look in world war ii we put japanese
people in internment camps let's
let's uh but he lives in mainland china
here's what i think i think that we have
to commit ourselves
as populists and nationalists to make
sure we don't get to a shooting war a
kinetic war with the chinese communist
party
in either taiwan the south china sea or
other parts in
in india we can't allow that that's
totally within our call to do
if we now wake up and
force the political class to
basically take on china in information
warfare and particularly economic if we
cut them off from capital markets the
dollar
90 days we could bring this criminal
organization to
its knees but we have to have the
political will to do it we must commit
ourselves
not to have a kinetic work because a
kinetic war i'm telling you
it could spin out of control and people
would be hit with weapons
uh weapons i think that people can't
even imagine today
oh yeah as bad as bad as wars and
nuclear wars remember
the cc this covid19 ain't the worst
thing they're cooking up in labs
have you in china okay the ccp have you
seen the infrared lasers they have
i have not so they have these gigantic
infrared lasers that can point
in the sky and just take down a plane or
a drone
imagine if you if you think you know the
weapons
of right now you have no idea this is my
point they've been developing stuff and
you'll never know about
a lot of lasers at a lens and focus i
mean that's just one thing
we cannot we must commit ourselves that
we would not by the way we are prepared
to
fight and win a kinetic war we must
never get there and the way
not to get there is to fight the
information cyber war now and to fight
the economic war
do you think it's going to look like the
russian uh dissolution of the soviet
power the chinese do you think you mean
the breaking up of china
into the warlords no i think hopefully
if we do this right we destroy and take
down the ccp and the people
a populist movement in china installs
democracy and they're able to go forward
they're going to have speed bumps
there's no doubt about it but no not to
break china would stay intact
all right chinese people uh svr wjr says
is war room hiring
reach out to my guys we're always
looking for we're always looking for
talent
talent you know we're we're i'm a pretty
good judge of horse flesh and we're
always looking for talent
all right we got uh we we've got so many
super chats i'll try and read a few more
but i definitely want to get
as much time in on the bonus segment as
possible uh because i feel like that
will be particularly spicy because rock
so let's just do uh we'll do a couple
more and sorry if i couldn't get to as
many people as we normally do
i talked a lot so many things to say
there's just a lot of comments that that
are like you know youtube is just
waiting with their finger over the
button ready to press ban so i'm like
trying to read through them and make
sure
you know more posse yeah yeah yeah so
we'll just do a couple more here and
i'll see i'll see if i can uh
find something um there's a lot of
questions for this i won't read anyone
particularly but a lot of people
are asking for your opinion on general
flynn
and what happened with all that mike
flynn is a great american he was
railroaded uh he's a good man
uh he's a tough guy he's always put the
country first
what happened to him and how in going
after him and and essentially trapping
him
to me shows you the danger of what the
fbi is up to uh
and what the the cia and these others
are up to that's why we have to have a
church commission
just look at general flynn look at his
record look what he's done as a patriot
hasn't made a nickel right he's a guy
he's always put his country first he's a
good man
he's a very good man and you're gonna
see a lot more general flynn in the
future
all right ian walker says so mr bannon
how do we end slavery if we need it
i doubt you will find an american who
does not want to end slavery
and yeah all i have to say about biden
is uh
he lost the stair race was any fell down
the stairs yeah
um yes how do we end slavery well we
talk about what's going on in china yeah
and i find it funny because during
occupy wall street there were a lot of
people pointing out that these young
people had iphones
and they would laugh and be like so what
i have an iphone it doesn't mean
anything and
i would be like i mean it's made by
slave laborers at foxconn who are
committing mass suicide it's a
horrifying story right
maybe you shouldn't buy apple products
it's also a bunch of other components
they make
but if americans love their luxury why
would they ever give that up
well i think there's a point that we
have to have a national commitment to
confront and to get our political class
and our economic class to confront the
chinese commerce party and guess what
we've got to bring some
foxconn promised false promises to bring
manufacturing back to wisconsin where
the taxpayers of wisconsin put it up
we have to have politicians and we have
to have their back populists have to
understand this
things may cost more that's not the end
of the world
your world's not going to collapse
because your iphone's more
but as soon as we get that you're going
to see a balance in the world you're
going to see a balance in the world
the chinese are going to be able to
manufacture stuff but they're going to
be able to pay people and they're going
to have
environmental regulation remember the
big scam in this in the climate change
and paris accord
is they're building more coal-fired
factories than ever doing they're
polluting the rivers more they're
killing the chinese people with what the
chinese countries party is putting in
the environment
right we can we can solve all that by
taking down the chinese campus party and
guess what bringing manufacturing back
here and
hey it's going to cost more if you're in
the republican party or
the orthodoxy they go oh you can't say
that you can't say things are going to
be
because people want from a consumerist
society
we have to change to a production
society once we turn to production
society
that's the key that picks the lock the
sunlit uplands
of a peaceful prosperous nation are
decades ahead of us but we have to make
that change today and we can make that
change it takes political will and
political will comes
from the will of the people to back
politicians that will do that
right on ladies and gentlemen you need
to go to timcast.com and sign up because
we're going to have a bonus segment
talking about a bunch of spicy topics
that'll be probably up around 11 or so
but maybe the conversation will end up
going long because i imagine
it will be spicy topics but don't forget
to like this video
subscribe to this channel if you're
listening on itunes or spotify share the
show
you can follow us on facebook and
instagram timecast irl where you can
help share our videos because we want to
leverage those platforms to get more
people to go to timcast.com
that's part of the big exodus plan i'm
hoping that in five or 10 years
we don't care so much about these social
media platforms because we have a
massive streaming platform of our own
with our own journalists
our own independent shows our own video
players all of that good stuff we need
your support to make that happen
all of you who are members right now
you've basically made it happen and
we're going to keep expanding we're
hiring like crazy and we're going to put
all of our
uh we're going to put all the risk up
front we're going to assume that because
look
with the success of this platform i do
not wish to buy an infinity pool i know
it breaks ian's heart i would like one
i want to hire another journalist i want
to hire more reporters i want to produce
more documentaries i want to challenge
the establishment
if at the end of my life i were to look
back at the things i
owned i would not be happy with a car
i'd be happy
with a team of a a bunch of news reports
that came out that had an impact that
helped improve the world and make
people's lives lives better so that's
timcast.com
check it out do you want to shout out
your uh podcast and your social media
just
go i don't know my social media because
my team does but just go to
warroom.org you get it every day real
america's voice
you get the podcast you get the live
stream you get everything at all the
library so we're there every day 10 a.m
to noon
live eastern time and then at five
o'clock for a one hour five o'clock show
so we're three hours a day and fight
six days a week we grind it and if you
go i think if you give it a shot
i think you'll become a participant i
think people like what we do which is
try to lay out information let people
come to their own decisions but give
them tools
of which we're an active activists come
to us we we are
all about human agency and action action
action not there to sit passively
i like a lot of talk ready which is all
great we just don't compete with that
but to do something different
right thank you so much for coming steve
no thank you guys for having me that's
great and by the way
one thing i gotta do my production team
has to who are here tonight
have to talk to the great producers this
is an amazing system
i mean actually my voice sounds the best
has ever sounded so it's not
particularly sophisticated to be honest
we don't use a tricaster anything fancy
like crowder does but uh
we got like stream decks it works we're
actually moving into a new studio in the
in the coming weeks wow it's very
exciting well you guys are great i was
real honored to be here tonight oh no
thank you for coming man i
appreciate it yeah this could have gone
and we'll go low and go but we got we
got more to talk about okay from
timcats.com it's coming up okay so
follow me at ian crossland.net and at
ian crossland on social media just blurt
that out there yeah dude
throw it out there so you guys should
all tune in to steve's podcast for sure
i'm gonna have to listen to that on the
way home and probably to this episode
again because i don't feel like i caught
everything that we talked about we went
through it
fast you guys are more than welcome to
follow me on twitter at sourpatchlids as
i attempt to have more followers and
sour patch kids
we will see you all at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out
you